А мне хочется, чтобы кто-то меняй был
сверху.
>> Блин, ну это получается надо сбрасывать
со скалы.
>> Ну подумайте о том, как попасть в
золотой миллиардходи.
>> А там война. Мне вообще насрать. Это
такой же грех. Поддержка мошенников и
убийц.
>> Он берёт кредит, потому что он [__] Не
охуительно живётся.
>> В какой-то степени осатонели все.
>> Ну я ухожу сейчас уже с подкаста.
>> Мне сейчас опять плакать.
>> Всё, Никит, я пошёл, [__] Ну ты хуйню
несёшь, в натуре. Ну потому что, [__]
я тебе говорю про президента, про
страну, про всю.
>> Сегодня обещанный подкаст с легендарным
Петром Лупенко. Наш первый подкаст
набрал уже 100.000 просмотров на Ютубе и
в ВК. Этот подкаст, обещаю, будет ещё
более интересным. Друзья, с вас лайк,
подписка, колокол, всё, что можно нажать
на Ютубе, на ВК, чтобы набрало
максимальное количество реакций.
>> Угу. Про что будем говорить?
>> Приветствую, Пётр.
>> Привет. Про что будем?
>> Рад тебя видеть.
>> Тоже рад
>> про всё будем говорить. Очень много
всего. У меня 50 вопросов к тебе. Пётр,
я тебе в прошлый раз обещал подарить
книгу. Собственно, вот она лежит. Я
предлагаю эту книгу обсудить на
следующем подкасте. Если это также
набирает 100.000гу,
>> то делаем продолжение. Как ты на это
смотришь?
>> Ну, я знаю эту книгу Год 2150. Я её
читал отчасти ну как бы коротко по
главам пробегал. Всегда хотел её
прочитать быстро. Я знаю про то, что там
человек в своём сознании видит будущее,
да, он пребывает в двух телах: в нашем
времени, ну, чуть-чуть в прошлом, да, и
в 11150 году, где человечество достигло
некоторого
некоторого сознания, в котором уже нет
страдания, эгоизма. и тому подобное. И
мне будет интересно её прочитать. Ну,
полностью.
>> Я не знаю, как показать, чтобы было
видно. Здесь написано: "Ты знаешь, кому
передать после прочтения".
>> Угу.
>> Мне её подарили.
>> В общем, одна такая очень очень
интересная девушка. А, и в общем,
>> а я также пишу: "Знаешь, кому
передарить".
>> Так, отлично.
Надеюсь, эту книгу потом найдут
где-нибудь археологи в 2150 году и
посмотрят, сколько люди.
>> Это тебе мой подарок.
>> Хошо. О'кей, ребят, кто читал, напишите,
как вам эта теория, потому что есть
много спорных моментов,
>> замечание от подписчиков. Вот сегодня ты
сидишь как бы ноги на полу. В прошлый
подкаст ты сидел ногу, ну как бы ногу на
ногу задрав, и люди пишут, типа вот это
там позиция неуважения или он говорит,
что там, короче, чакру в первую там это
блокирует, как бы блокирует. Точно,
>> блокируют, конечно. Ну то,
>> ну, потому что у меня, я это делаю, люди
сидят нога на ногу, когда у них
протекает, короче, когда у тебя есть
страхи или непроработанные родители, ты
кладёшь ногу, потому что у тебя таким
образом перекрещивается энергия. Это
довозкие практики в целом. Это вредно
делать, чтобы у тебя не перетекала
энергия в нижние чакры, потому что здесь
они у тебя крутятся по по малой орбите.
Ты как бы их оставляешь в верхних
центрах. Когда ты так делаешь, оно у
тебя циркулирует. Но так как у меня в
моменте были болезни, депрессия,
непроработанные родители, это
психосоматическое движение, которое
перекрывает канал. То есть, если вы вот
так спите, скорее всего, вот так,
допустим, если вы лежите, скорее всего,
у вас есть страхи либо непроработка
родителей. Я так сижу исключительно,
потому что мне это психосоматическая
поза сдерживания энергии. Но когда
человек видит, что это он видит в этом
гордыню, да, или надменность какую-то,
это есть в нём самом.
>> Проработал родителей за это время,
получается,
>> ой, до сих пор прорабатывают. Ну, уже
сидишь вот так.
>> Ну, видимо,
>> нормально. Ну, ладно, подписчикам, если
объяснить, они перестают бомбить. В
общем, ладно.
>> Не, когда тебя кто-то бесит, нужно
смотреть, почему тебя, допустим,
допустим, я вот так сел, да, человека
сразу вызывает отвращение. Почему у него
отвращение? Ну, что в этой
>> он себе так не разрешает, потому что,
>> ну, потому что он хочет он хочет быть
значимым, важным, и, скорее всего, в
своей душе он пренебрегает другими
людьми. И поэтому, когда он видит такую
позу, он думает, что вот я такой плохой,
но это зеркало всегда. Ну да, это в его
картине мира. То есть он, если так
сядет, он подошву там демонстрирует,
типа вот ты, короче, быдла,
>> а я, так сказать, молодец.
>> Ну да, так и есть. В общем, смотри,
подкаст большинству зашёл. Но есть, ну
там даже про политику у нас был такой
блок прикольный, там некоторые пишут:
"Голосуйте за Лупенко". А некоторые
пишут, короче, Лупенко на вила. Лупенко
на вила. Почему? Потому что ты сказал:
"Давай отменяем пенсии". И там люди
говорят: "Так, короче, смотри, у
человека нету, не знаю, там возможности
родить, там болезни какие-то, да? То
есть у человека там, не знаю, страна
развалилась, там валюта обесценилась,
да, и так далее. То есть так у нас уже
было.
>> И бац, он ещё и без пенсий. Ну и всё,
короче, вымер.
>> Ну давай контекст отбросим назад,
отменяем пенсии. Почему? Я говорил о
том, что скорее всего, если я правильно
помню, про финансовую грамотность, да,
что каждый человек может себе,
>> да,
>> тем самым прокачивая экономику страны
откладывать, например, на ОФЗ. Вот,
допустим, сейчас мы с тобой сидим,
облигации федерального займа на 15 лет
15%. Это исторический рекорд. И если вот
после прямой линии с президентом
действительно будут опускать ставку вот
так вот по одному, по полпроцента, то
это космические деньги. То есть ты за 15
лет себе в скопишь такую пенсию, которую
ты не скопишь и за 70 лет, потому что
это гигантский процент. Пенсионная
реформа устроена так, что люди платят,
отдают часть денег, которые потом
государство прокручивает во всевозможных
делах. Да, естественно, дела могут быть
когда-то неудачными, когда-то удачны, но
ОФЗ, облигации федерального займа - это
самая стабильная бумага, и ты, например,
через неё можешь скопить себе пенсию. Я,
например, покупаю сейчас ОФЗ, я могу
даже номер сказать, чтобы люди покупали,
пока оно ещё есть. Вот сейчас Путин
объявил, что они снижают, по-моему, на
0,5%. И если эта ставка будет падать,
тело ОФЗ будет расти. Короче, я к чему
говорю, что таким образом человек,
откапливая себе пенсию, например, он и
государству помогает, и себе помогает, и
он обеспечен, и все обеспечены. Я не
понимаю смысл пенсии, потому что пенсия
она, когда человек на неё только
рассчитывает, да, то есть он ээ он как
будто лишает себя всех
финансово-грамотных инструментов.
Понятное дело, что есть люди
незащищённые, это которые нуждающиеся, у
которых там проблемы со здоровьем,
естественно, их нужно обеспечивать.
>> Вредное производство, опять же, вот
человек до 45 лет.
Я я имею в виду, что когда ты думаешь о
том, что тебе только должно твоё будущее
обеспечить государство, мне кажется,
странный подход, потому что ты должен
государство - это как бы ещё один
источник, который, да, поможет тебе, но
если ты только от них ждёшь, это позиция
как будто ты никогда не был взрослым. То
есть ты реально ждёшь до пенсии, да, там
до 50-60 лет, ты ждёшь, что тебе кто-то
потом её отдаст. Ну, типа для меня это
очень странно. Я привык брать
ответственность за свою жизнь. Мне также
государство поможет, и я ему помогу,
потому что облигации федерального
назваемая - это долг государства. Но это
человек, ну, это нужно это нужно
финансовую грамотность прокачивать. То
есть любой человек, с которым я общаюсь,
у кого есть финансовый портфель, он
говорит: "Я сам себе делаю пенсию".
>> Ну, естественно, ну предпринимателей у
нас ну менее 1% населения. То есть,
соответственно, у остальных финансовая
грамотность такая базовая, все такие
вкачанные ребята. И, соответственно,
человек вкладывает в, ну, валюта,
которая обесценивается, да, пенсионный
фонд, который сегодня взяли и
реорганизовали, например, завтра его
нет. Вот в Советском Союзе в девяностые
кто-то там откладывал что-то, там деньги
вкладывал, потом через год эти деньги
можно, так сказать, было в печку топить.
>> Ну так диверсифицируй, ты же не должен в
одно вкладывать. Вложи в ОФЗ, вложи
какую-нибудь техники, купи, купи крипты,
купи ещё. У тебя должны быть всё по
разным кон То есть это позиция ребёнка,
когда он говорит: "Ой, да будет
инфляция. Ой, страна развалится. Ой, ещё
ты, если ты умный человек, если ты
просто пару книжек прочитал или хотя бы
пару блогеров посмотрел на эту тему, ты
себе обеспечишь будущее.
>> Ну вот для детей же всё-таки надо как-то
обеспечить детей.
Что когда отменять-то?
>> А как родитель научит своего ребёнка,
если он себя не научил?
>> Ну, блин, как ребёнка на мороз вот
выгнал там, типа, и иди гуля.
>> Ну вот он себя пусть на мороз выгонит и
поучится. То есть это же можно обвинять
государство, можно обвинять кого угодно,
что там пенсии будет, не будет или там
вот я предложил. Я говорю, я не вижу
смысла. И пусть это будет просто налог,
который пойдёт на государство, чтобы
облагоустраивать территории все наши,
тем более в тяжёлое время. Человек, я я
на полном серьёз говорю, если бы мы
сейчас ввели финансовую грамотность в
школах, чтобы дети, например, не знаю,
по 1.000 руб. в месяц откладывали себе
на ОФЗ в будущее, ты уже закончил
университет, у тебя есть на обучение.
Вот в будущем, кстати, в этой книге вот
истории, которые уже давно давно давно
прошли вот этот этап, о котором ты
сейчас говоришь. Это уже и финансовая
грамотность там, и уже безденежная
система, там очень интересно всё
описано. Ну, то есть пока денежная, но
надо её освоить, да, в ней жить, а потом
она постепенно перетекает в безденежную.
Это очень, очень прикольно. И вот насчёт
пенсии, ну, то есть знаешь, у меня
ощущение, что вот то, о чём ты говоришь,
это очень круто, это прямо рост,
эволюция, и вот, ну, есть люди, которые
не хотят, не могут по разным причинам,
да, вот вот так, как ты говоришь.
По каким?
>> Ну, то есть смотри, есть человек живёт в
каком-нибудь городе маленьком, там одно
предприятие, оно вредное, и таких очень
много у нас моногородов. То есть у нас
где-то 70% людей получают зарплату около
50 000 руб. в стране, понимаешь? И это
как бы люди вот маленький город, ма, то
есть у них, во-первых, они бы рады,
может, в Москву и всё как бы хотят, что
ты говоришь. Ну, блин, а дайте мне денег
на месяц, чтобы пожить в Москве, хату
снять нету. Отдайте. А и 70%
закредитованных, понимаешь, людей. То
есть они вот вроде бы и рады, может. Ну,
ну это долгая история. Тыто говоришь,
как будто они вот эти кредиты пришёл
дядя и повесил им кредит какой-то. Ну ты
же понимаешь,
>> понятно, что они сами, но как бы
государство оно вот и есть как вот такой
гарант, чтобы людей вообще вот эта вся
финансовая система не перемолола и ну то
есть хоть оставьте хоть какую-то базу,
то есть вот 8 м², да, человек остался
без ничего. Ну прямо что-то произошло,
ну прямо трагедия у человека.
>> И вот остался без ничего. Вот
по-разному. Там с бомжами е поговоришь,
там реально вот у кого сгорело что-то, у
кого там жена ушла, он в депрессию впал,
не смог вылезти. И по-разному бывает. И
вот ну заболел кто-то, да, там понятно,
если ты заболел, ну, как бы поддержка
какая-то. То есть вот я же говорю, для
таких людей было бы, конечно, если там
вредное производство ещё тому подобное.
Я говорю, вот обычный человек, вот он
среднестатистический, например, мы не
берём уже советское поколение, у которых
ментал вырос там, да, в в советское
время это уже невозможно. Но вот Зумер
вырастет, ты думаешь, Зумер будет о
пенсии думать? среднестатистический,
сейчас зарплата примерно у 50-70, не
помню там по-разному, около 50.000 руб.
Вот 50-70% 50.000 руб. получает. Всё.
Вот ни в чём себе не отказывай, как
говорится.
>> Вот смотри, вот подкаст позавчера
записывал. У меня на канале выйдет
Санаром с канала на пенсию в 35 лет. Он
инвестор предприниматель один из самых
известных. Я у него был на канале, он у
меня был на канале, мы это обсуждали. Я
ему задал такой же вопрос: "Вот смотри,
как вот человеку инвестировать в будущее
и тому подобное. Вот у него зарплата
50-70.000." Он говорит: "Первоначальная
цель утроить свой заработок". Когда ты
ставишь себе такую цель, вот ты
перестаёшь, во-первых, жаловаться.
Говоришь: "Вот у людей зарплаты 50.000,
но у кого-то же есть 150".
>> Да.
>> Ну так почему ты думаешь, что ты не
можешь сделать 150? Ну ты спроси себе,
как мне стать лучше, как специалист? Там
есть целая иерархия в устройстве
социального общества. Ты должен
перепрыгнуть вверх. Ты должен из
работника стать специалистом. То есть,
допустим, можно быть поваром в школьной
столовой, а можно быть поваром в
ресторане в Москве, да, допустим, или
даже там в Краснодаре, откуда я родом,
да, там хорошо шефы получают. Можно в
столовой получать 50.000, можно быть
шефом или там хотя бы обычным порм 150
получать. Вопрос в том, что пока ты
думаешь, что вот такие зарплаты - это
установка, Марк Аврелий пишет ещё век до
нашей эры. Убери убеждения и уведут
страдания. То есть у тебя есть
убеждение, что зарплата 50.000 и
государство тебя не обеспечит пенсией
или обеспечит мало. Ты в этом и будешь
жить. Ну то есть у тебя есть выбор
выскочить. То есть ты можешь сказать:
"Да я я ставлю себе цель. Я же не говорю
ему полтора млна зарабатывать или 150".
Ну подумать, как как из 50 сделать 150.
>> То, о чём ты говоришь, Пётр, это,
знаешь, в социологии написано
определение модальной тип личности - это
самые сильные особи любой популяции. Их
порядка 8% в любой популяции. То есть
это нонконформисты, это те, которые
антисистемщики, которые всегда там не
согласны и так далее. Это те, кто
мыслит. И, соответственно, самые такие
прорывные, пробивные, активные, такие
вот доминантные такие особи. И вот они
как бы, да, то есть они и
предприниматели, и всёвсёвсё. Остальная
масса она вот вот она другая. И когда
говорится, что вот все так могут, [__]
нет, не могут.
>> Нет, не все так не могут. Но, но, но
смотри, если мы говорим про уровень
жизни, когда ты говоришь, там
минимальная зарплата 50 и 150, ты
говоришь, там одно производство в городе
и тому подобное, при желании, вот именно
желании из псяти перейти в 150, это
возможно. Есть интернет, есть что
угодно. Это Это не так, что тебя к
батарее пристегнули и сказали: "Здесь ты
работаешь". Ну, это так не работает.
>> Ну вот, знаешь, у меня сейчас
благодарность родилась, Пётр, вот нашему
государству, президенту. Всё-таки оно,
знаешь, вот социализм он как бы, знаешь,
в народе где-то уже в генах у нас прово.
>> И вот то есть война, так сказать, по
сути социалистическая система победила
вот капиталистическую, условно так, и
вот это как бы такая наша база. То есть
8 м² государство гарантирует базовую
пенсию, чтобы ты выжил, не вымер,
медицину. В США такого нет. Всё, у тебя
деньги кончились, иди вымри.
>> Понимаешь, у нас дают любовь, сказать,
всё-таки человеколюбие. Всё-таки я вот
за это больше
>> Нет, да нет, я тоже согласен за это. Я
про то, что не нужно. Короче, смотри, ты
можешь смириться. Ты говоришь, там
массовая. Ну да, да, так и есть. Но ты
можешь смириться, можешь что-то делать.
Ну вот что, ну что делать?
>> Я вот тоже говорю, знаешь, быть вне
элиты мастеров сейчас преступно. Все
знания открыты. У тебя в кармане все
знания человечества. Ты сидишь,
залипаешь парнушку там и игры
какие-нибудь онлайн.
>> Так вот тоже. И ты говоришь, что все
виноваты, все у тебя виноваты. Не, не,
ты, я го человек,
>> все не могут. Все не могут. Просто они
вот залипли и всё. Они будут будут
наркоманами, но кто-то вылезет, а кто-то
нет. Ну вот их как-то от них надо
позаботься. Это
>> эволюция, ты понимаешь, что он должен
дойти до того, что в какой-то момент ему
осточертело и он начинает что-то делать
другое.
>> Блин, ну это получается надо сбрасывать
со скалы слабых там всех.
>> Мир так и делает. Тебя сбросит, если ты
слабый. Ты понимаешь, в чём прикол? Это
так устроен мир. Если ты слабый, ты не
выживаешь.
>> Надеюсь, прояснили. А был ещё вопрос,
очень много вопросов про историю.
>> История, а там вот ещё про, короче,
модель, типа финансовая модель. Вот
откладывать, откладывать. Почему,
говорит, у нас это не будет работать? У
нас уже несколько раз поменялась валюта,
фактически поменялась, то есть
обесценилась очень много раз.
>> В США она с тридцатых годов после
Великой депрессии сильно не
обесценивалась. То есть вот у них по,
ну, 100 лет стабильности. У нас вот так
постоянно, короче, колашматит. Поэтому
как откладывать, что откладывать? То
есть это надо быть, короче, лютым
инвестором там, ну, прокачанным, чтобы у
нас вот в таких, так сказать, в такой
турбулентности что-то делать,
>> да? Почему? Смотри, вот я всегда привожу
вот этот пример банальный со своими
зубами. Вот у меня зубы сделаны, они
стоят 1,5 млн руб. Я, чтобы сделать эти
зубы, увидел.
>> Ты вроде говорил 400.000.
>> Нет, пол млна. 300 400 300.000 ли
сначала элайнеры надеть и потом, короче,
там всё вместе, по-моему, полтора млна
вышло.
>> И я что сделал? Вот момент, когда
золото лежало, когда ВК лежал, се он и
сейчас лежит, но он один раз дал 30%,
аэрофлот лежал, я просто пошёл туда,
вложил деньги. Это было 3 года назад. В
какой-то момент я поворачиваюсь, и у
меня просто огромный буст. И я снимаю
эти деньги и делаю себе зубы.
Спекулятивные любые махинации - это не
работа. Это вы вступаете в эгрегор
спекулянтов. То есть прикол в том, ты
там всё, когда у тебя не волатильно, ой,
точнее, когда у тебя всё непредсказуемо
- это самый большой и реальный способ
заработать. Никто не читал
антихрупкость, не читал антихрупкость.
Это вообще это потрясающе. Она очень
сложная книга. Антихрупкость - это книга
про то, как зарабатывать в кризисе. То
есть что происходит в кризис? Люди
начинают теряться, да? Они думают, там
государство плохое, ещё что-то. У нас
валюта не такая, но самая волатильная
валюта, да, которая прыгает - это самый
большой источник заработка. Например,
биткои, если взять биткоин - это валюта,
которая вот так вот скачет. Но именно на
ней, если она сейчас упала до 80, вот
сейчас она упала до 80.000, вложи туда,
ты заберёшь, она опять будет 120 или
200. А все покупают, когда она уже 120.
И вот так же и тут. Я говорю, я просто
смотрел, что вот он ВК, все пишут ВК
будет лежать. Я кладу, у меня плюс 30%.
Я замечательно пошёл зубы сделал.
Аэрофлот, говорит, никто не будет
летать. Все санкции, мы все умрём.
Аэрофлот даёт, я пошёл. Золото, золото
пошло. Ну вы что, не знаете моё
мнение про трейдинг? Э вообще считаю,
что спекулятивные любые махинации - это
не работа. Это выступаете в эгрегор
спекулянта. Про антихрупкость, ребят,
антихрупкость прочитать, она очень
большая, очень сложная, но там именно
про то, что ты в период сложностей
должен увидеть самый большой источник
заработка, потому что там, где
стабильно, например, то же самое в
американский рынок, да, у тебя средний
индекс SMP500 всех акций, они будут
давать тебе, ну, дай бог, процентов
шесть.
Ну просто это
>> много у нас было в прошлый раз про
историю. Там народ кто-то восхитился,
кто-то сказал что-то долгодушно. А, но в
любом случае там очень много вопросов
типа Пётр, неужели ты не понимаешь,
зачем знать историю? Да, кто не понял
своё прошлое, вынужден пережить его
снова. Это как кармический урок выучить,
да? То есть не знаешь прошлое, как бы,
ну, будешь вот как это бесконечный, так
сказать, биатлонный круг, да, промазал
опять на биатлонный круг, на штрафной.
>> И
>> как бы история, ты говоришь, ведёт, ну,
вот типа история с потопом, да, в тему
матрицы. И то есть мне, ну, пишут, типа,
ты не раскрыл тему, а я действительно не
раскрыл. Сейчас один, ну, как бы
маленький, может быть, даже вставим сюда
вот этот фрагмент, где Путин приезжает к
Ментимиру Шаймиеву, президенту
Татарстана в 2000, по-моему, тринадцато
году и дарит ему карту Великой Тартарии.
>> Угу.
>> XV века.
>> То есть он знаково показывает на камеру.
Смотрите, ребята, XV век, Тартария
включает в себя пол Европы, часть Китая
до северной, так сказать, вот этой
китайской стены.
А эта территория сейчас уже под Китаем,
понимаешь? Да. То есть они захватили и
то есть огромная территория называется
Великая Тартария. Путин дарит вот эту
карту.
>> Угу.
>> Шайми его. Потом они с Шайгу приезжают в
музей РГО и там несколько дарят типа
летописей музею и прямо открывают на
странице Великая Тартария. То есть они
таким образом дают послание народу.
Смотрите, ребята, вот что мы хотим
рассказать миру. Вот смотрите. То есть
мы как бы мало того, что правопреемники
Советского Союза, а Советский Союз
Российской империи, а Российская империя
Тартарии, это было до вот этой вот
истории с засыпкой. И вот эта история
ведёт туда. И то есть вот когда ты
говоришь, там эта тема конфликтует там с
государственным эгрегором и типа уводит
там людей, ни хрена, ни хрена подобно.
То есть Путин бы не стал эти темы
двигать, если бы не понимал, он там про
монгольские иг говорил, что это всё
фуфло. То есть вот я маленькую ремарочку
вставляю про историю. Вот сейчас
предлагаю не останавливаться. Погнали
дальше в эзотерику нашу.
>> Не, пон, ты же это рассказал, а ты же
дашь мне прокомментировать. Но ты
говоришь, если ты не знаешь историю, как
ты поймёшь уроки? Какой урок ты выносишь
с того, что была Тартария?
>> Урок, а очень хороший. У нас, кстати,
недавно на антиутопии вышел ролик уроки
истории, которые Россия обязана выучить.
Можете посмотреть коротко. То есть как
только элита видит, ну вот мы видим
историю Российской империи. Угу.
>> Верхи не хотят, низы не могут. Элита не
слышит низ, низ не слышит элиту. Всё,
развал страны, [__] гордыня. Все
подербанились на мелкие государства,
наплодили языков искусственных, и сейчас
все воюют. Сейчас Советский Союз
распался. Ещё больше наплодило всяких
республик, государств, ещё больше языков
наплодилось у всех гордыня в Вавилонской
башне. То есть мы имеем библейский
проект Вавилонская башня. Говорят на
непонятном языке. Все как бы сами круче
Бога. Всё. И вот, собственно, вот этот
урок-то давайте усвоим. То есть вот он,
вот он, он повторяется, он повторяется.
>> Кто кто усвоим?
>> Все.
>> Ну,
>> все. То есть мы часть единой системы. Ты
говорил, мы с тобой единая душа и мы все
единая душа. Давайте все усвоим.
>> Конечно, что мы усвоим? Ну вот ты
сказал: "О'кей, как мы усвоим это?"
Смотри, очень просто. Вот как минимум
сейчас урок с Украиной, он вот о чём
говорит. Ты говоришь, они оторвались от
ментальности. До этого также оторвались
от ментальности Болгария, Польша,
Финляндия, ещё ряд стран оторвались от
ментальности. Казахстан, и они
отрываются, отрываются, отрываются. То
есть смотрите, и у всех [__] Вот всех,
кто отрывается от государства, там
Латвия, Литва, то есть раньше там, ну,
как бы промышленность была, всё было
развито, сейчас там [__] То есть раньше
была, говорит, фасадом Советского Союза,
а сейчас [__] Европы, понимаешь? И это
как бы реально [__] И и и они не могут
понять, что вот почему так херово.
>> А что ты за них переживаешь? Это же они
смотри, мы если мыслим масштабам своей
кухни,
>> то мы видим вот вот у меня всё хорошо, а
там война, мне вообще насрать. Или ты
мыслишь немножко более масштабно, ты
видишь, блин, то есть если я там часть
единой вот, так сказать, вот этого
сознания, как ты видишь, да, или там
часть страны, я как бы делаю для страны.
Если я там себя идентифицирую, там
только семья, вот я только для семьи, я
говорю твоей отве твоей ответственности
хватит на это.
>> Ну смотри, кто-то вот идёт на Донбасс,
помогает. У вот твоих хватает вот
сделать туда, сказать.
>> Ну я отправляю деньги.
>> Вот я никогда не рассказываю про свои
благотворительные истории, потому что
этого нельзя делать. Это нельзя говорить
даже мужу, детям, потому что награда
человека, который рассказал про свою
благотворительность - это поощрение
общества.
>> Всё. И кто в меру возможности также всё.
Вот у меня прямая поль деньги и
отправляю на СВО. Вот я беру и
отправляю.
>> Всё,
>> всё. Вот это моя ответственность. Какая
мне нахрен тартария? Что я от этого
пойму? Или от того, что там ещё?
Историческая правда. Вот сейчас наши
активно отстаивают историческую правду
по
>> Угу.
>> Великой Отечественной войне.
>> То есть США её конкретно, ну, как бы
искажает, говорит, что это они выиграли.
Наши говорят: "Нет, мы выиграли".
>> Ну, то есть
есть такой историк, аналитик классный
Андрей Фурсов. Очень рекомендую. Кто не
знает, шикарный дядька. Он очень хорошо
вот по истории глубоко копает. Он
говорит: "Если бы мы, ну, наша элита
усвоила вот эти уроки, поняла и народ бы
поддержал",
>> да не может он думать, что думает элита.
Никита, потому что у него единая
система, это силита это люди более
развиты.
>> Народ поддерживает. Смотри, элита она
она отражает интересы большой группы
людей.
>> Это люди отражают интересы элиты. Давай
смотреть реально на Да нет, ну просто
что мы себе врём. Элиты - это люди, это
их интересы отражаются вниз, а не вниз,
наверх. И пока люди живут в этой
иллюзии, что типа тебе кто-то сверху
должен, это так не будет работать.
>> Ну то же самое я создаю эту реальность
или я раб божий или я раб божий. У тебя
у тебя есть возможность прыгать до верха
до элит, если ты этого хочешь. Если ты
этого не хочешь, ты у тебя смотри какая
эмоция. Ты говоришь: "Меня обманули
сверху". Ты говоришь: "Вот там элиты,
меня обманули, от меня скрывают
историю".
>> Ненене, не меня обманули. Смотри, я
говорю, мы должны понять вот эту историю
с Советским Союзом, историю с Российской
>> импери пом прикол. У тебя есть жизнь
твоя твоя. Вот на что ты можешь там
влиять? На на свою женщину, на своих
детей.
>> Сейчас, сейчас сейчас. Пётр, США, ты
любишь приводить пример США? Смотри, у
них герб, гимн, они гордятся своей
историей, хотя она придуманная. Она
придуманная. У нас есть шикарная
история, просто богатейшая. А мы её не
знаем. Мы её вообще А нахер её знать?
>> Никита, почему тебя волнуют другие люди?
Я говорю, ты если любишь историю,
>> ребто, есть, ну, есть человек, который
мыслит только масштабом своей кухни, а
есть человек, ну, понятие такое, масштаб
личности, определяется тем, что он
вмещает в своё я. Вот я говорю, моя
семья есть, у меня есть родня, у меня
есть ещё моя общественная деятельность,
да, люди, которым я помогаю, есть мой
клуб для, ну сказать, людей, которые там
в депрессии, у которых психосоматика,
депрессия там и проблемы в отношениях.
То есть вот я расширяю это некое, вот,
знаешь, на на что я влияю.
>> Угу.
>> И вот кто-то влияет там, знаешь, вот на
масштаб страны.
>> Кона польза. Какая конкретная польза?
>> Конкретная польза. Смотри, мы качаем
тему Тартарии.
>> Путин через где-то года-два выходит с
этой картой. То есть она становится
популярной народе, она вирусится. Элита
видит, что эта идея очень-очень активно
продвигается, и выходит человек, который
озвучивает эту идею, и весь народ бежит.
Ну, как вот помнишь в нацистской
Германии, то есть там была нищета, да,
вышел какой-то момент человек, который
озвучил то, что хотел слышать народ.
Ура, побежали, понимаешь? По-моему, это
всё вода. Вот смотри, ты говоришь, что,
допустим, что я, если мои рассуждения -
это мысли в своей кухне, у меня
рассуждения какие? Да, я люблю свою
страну. Я хочу, чтобы люди в ней жили
хорошо. Что я могу сделать? Я могу
отправить деньги на СВО, я могу
вкладывать деньги в фондовый рынок,
создавать рабочие места, что я и делаю,
>> понимаешь? Вот на что я способен, я это
делаю. Всё. Зачем мне? Я не думаю туда,
там элиты, ещё что-то. То есть у них
каждый человек за себя. У нас мы все
едины. То есть у нас один умрёт за
другого.
>> Вот о чём я и говорю. Вот за что я
обожаю с тобой интервью. Мы с тобой
можем, знаешь, как бы вот с разных
позиций, то есть у нас есть с тобой
очень как бы разные диаметральные точки.
А мы можем на них раз с другой стороны
посмотреть, и оказывается они с какой-то
точки зрения они стыкуются. То есть это
это прикольно. Мне очень нравится всегда
стыковать.
Мне не интересно противопоставление.
Спасибо. Я говорю, практическая польза
от этого какая? Пое практическая.
Смотри, есть у нас пропаганда, которая
антисемейная, алкогольная,
наркотическая, проплачивает финансовую
мафию. И есть люди, которые разлоблачают
эту ложь. И люди, которые поняли,
бросили бухать, бросили курить, создали
семью.
>> Нет, они не от этого бросили бухать.
этого они не знали. Смотри, мы выложили
ролик на Кромоле про бухло. Люди не
знали эту пропаганду, не понимали
принципы, увидели, узнали, поняли,
бросили бухать. Ребят, спасибо. Вот
доймер. Достойный пример. Хорошо. Я же
говорю, тартария как поможет людям.
>> Тартария, смотри, цените историю,
уважайте корни, уважайте предков,
уважайте традицию. Поймите, что вы
влияете. Вот вы, если вас что-то не
устраивает, например, в вашем городе,
районе, регионе, вы можете собрать
круглый стол, вы можете пойти в
депутаты, вы можете влиять на решение
депутатов. Вот с разных сторон можете
влиять, понимаешь? Есть люди, которые
судятся за химтрейлы. Знаешь такого
дядьку Денис Шульга? Потрясающий дядька.
Он юрист, знаешь, химтрейлы же, да? Вот
эти вот полоски на небе. Ну то есть там
распыляют что-то, но точно ничего-то
ничего хорошего. И он юридически
доказал, что это дичь распыляют. В Китае
это уже давно как бы признано, что это
дичь мы ничего не будем распылять. В
Испании это признано, что это дичь мы не
будем распылять. У нас там типа говорит:
"Этого ничего нет". Хотя полоски на небе
всё как бы говорят, что это всё есть. И
он юридически говорит: "Так вот в этом
регионе, короче, мы запрещаем химтрей".
Такие говорит: "Да, да, да,
действительно, да, всё". То есть,
понимаешь, каждый каждый на своём месте.
Кто говорит: "Вышку 5G уберите нахер от
моего дома". Юридически пошёл, сделал
всё. И, соответственно, про, например,
какой-то регион. Мы, говорит,
цифровизацию образования хотим, а люди
говорят: "Мы не хотим роботов вместо
учителей". Пошли, отстояли свои права,
говорит, мы для детей хотим там
нормальных живых учителей. Всё,
отстояли. То есть у каждого вот свой
масштаб влияния. У каждой, на сколько
хватает сил, энергии, он влияет. Всё. И
я вот до того хочу, как сказать, на этом
вопросе остановиться, что вот хватает
тебя на это, классно. Больше можешь,
можешь, не можешь, не лезь. Всё. Вот
если хочешь залезть там в тему
идеологии, там какой-то, знаешь,
метафизики и как-то вот повлиять на ум и
на сознание людей, подготовить там
сказать общественное мнение к этому,
вперёд. Иди. Это пропаганда. Это как бы
сейчас
>> от меня утаили карту, от меня утаили то.
>> Убеждать людей в чём-то, кого мы
убеждаем,
>> да? Я не знаю, кого ты убеждашь. Ты
должен убеждать.
>> Ну ты помнишь тогда говорил типа,
Никита, в чём твоя ложь? Там у тебя,
говоришь, профдеформация разборщика.
говорю: "А в чём твоя выгода убеждать?
Кого ты убеждаешь, убеждая людей
вокруг?"
>> Кого я? Кого что убеждаю? Да я ко мне
приходит человек, я ему помогаю, на этом
деньги зарабатываю, я ему помощь, и за
это я могу рекламу какую-то вставить.
Это взаимовыгода. У меня нет никакой
миссии там. Сегодня у нас большая
миссия, и я хочу, чтобы сегодня каждый,
кто посмотрел этот подкаст, в конце смог
понять, кто он, чем ему заниматься, как,
не знаю, уйти с нелюбимой работы, найти
любимую работу и в целом обрести своё
предназначение, там, пробудить людей. Я
понимаю зону своей ответственности. Вот
есть человек, я с ним энергообен, он ко
мне пришёл на консультацию, я ему
бесплатно её делаю, но за это я могу
что-то прорекламировать. Я не несу себе
изменить человечество.
>> Смол, что бы ты сделал?
>> Я бы делал художественные произведения,
в которых бы тонкими смыслами внедрял бы
э нарративы о нравственности, о
добродетеле, о щедрости, об уважении к
родителям и тому подобное.
>> У кого-то есть миссия. Это разве плохо?
>> Нет, это это неплохо. Я говорю о том,
что когда мы вот если мы изначально в
эту Тартарию придём, изначально эмоции
от меня что-то утаили тут.
>> Не утаили. Мы просрали урок, грубо
говоря. Вот есть как родовые
расстановки. Вот повторяется урок по
роду.
>> Кто мы?
>> Не выучил урок по роду? Ну не знаю, ты
сын своего отца, деда, там, прадеда,
внук. То есть не выучил урок, будешь
повторять, повторять, повторять.
>> Вещи, которые вот такие вот такого
порядка большого, это доступно менять
только элитам, у которых власть есть на
это. Вот смотри, сейчас я тебе приведу
прямо чёткий пример, когда мы, создав
огромное движение вот это вот про
Тартарию, про этого не было, потому что
первая Икрамола начала снимать фильмы
про Тартарию, крутые документальные
фильмы, большие, прямо мощные. И через
где-то 2 года после этого Путин идёт с
картой, понимаешь? То есть это
подготовило общественное мнение к тому,
что элиты смотрят сверху, говорят: "А
народ готов, нормально". То есть смотри,
у нас в Европе разница тоже как вот
народ готовит, ну, скажем так, как элита
и народ стыкуются. То есть в Европе
народ м ну условно укализация была, вот
эта шмурдизация 2020 год, и там всех
прокололи, и никто ничего, сказать, не
вякнул. У нас народ тотально быстовал
против масок, против этих укализаций. И
Путин говорит: "Мы всё добровольно,
добровольно, добровольно в какой-то
стране". Сначала говорит: "Всех
жёсткцинируем там, короче,
принудительно. Народ раз бастует. Ой,
ладно, добровольно. То есть вот так это
работает. Антиваксер, правильно?
>> Вот так это работает. Антиваксер - это
херовое, Пётр, название, чтобы обоссать.
Вот как знаешь, эзотериков называют
эзотериками, чтобы
>> ши эзотериками или эзотери. Ни один
эзотерик себя не называет эзотериком.
>> Эзотериков называют эзотериками те, кто
хочет их обоссать и на их фоне сказать:
"Ой, я крутой молодец. Тоже самое
антиваксер, но ты не прививался,
правильно?"
>> То есть, смотри, я за вакцины, которые
под тебя непосредственно сделаны,
проверен твой иммунитет, реакция на
вещества. Это безопасно для тебя и это
капец как дорого. Я вот за такие, а то,
что колят всем без разбора, не проверяя
и куча, кто-то дохнет, кто-то становится
инвалидом, у кого-то ДЦП, у кого-то
аутизм после этого. Вот я против этой
херни.
>> У тебя недоверие идёт, ты не доверяешь.
Ну смотри, в этом-то и есть смысл. А как
ты истину познаешь, если ты не будешь
сомневаться?
>> А нахера я должен доверять?
>> Ты не доверяешь элите, поэтому у тебя
такая боль.
>> Причём здесь элита-то? Ну смотри, элита
может ошибаться, элита может врать.
>> Угу. Соответственно, я сомневаюсь. Я
говорю: "Может, мне врут, а может, и не
врут. Дайте я перепроверю, перепроверяю,
там реально [__] Не надо меня,
пожалуйста, принуждать". То есть я
дееспособен, я не инвалид. Я не хочу,
чтобы мне что-то навязывали.
>> Помнишь наш разбор?
>> Про ответственность в конце будет очень
большой блок. Пётр, предлагаю гнать. У
нас мало времени. Смотри, блиц из семи
вопросов просто. Да. Нет. А транссёрфинг
- это эзотерика или нет?
>> Да. Чакры эзотерика.
>> Нет,
>> вот это поворот.
>> Так, обряды очищения себя дома свечкой.
Эзотерика,
>> да?
>> Угу. Эгрегор - это эзотерика,
>> Так, а вот вся история там зивота, выход
негативной энергии, это вот чистка
негативной энергии.
>> Нет, это просто это так негатив выходит.
>> Ну, типа чистка негатив энергии.
>> Не, ну если ты именно про чистку
говоришь, именно когда чистят там, ну,
это уже магия. Угу.
>> У меня вообще любые вот такие практики
по энергоочению, это просто квантовая
физика, до которой не дошли.
>> Хорошо. А, ну целительство это магия.
>> Это магия. Хорошо. А подключки,
сущности?
>> Их нет. Вот лярвочка была. [смех]
>> Не, она у вас есть ещё? Конечно,
>> подключ. О, уже нет
>> их. Нет.
>> Хотя у тебя были в клубе, я помню.
>> Всё, уже новый новая инфа пере Ну
>> удалил.
Не, не удалил. Смотри, когда у тебя
какой-то это зажимы в теле твоей, они
просто это электрические заряды. То есть
когда ты копишь какую-то эмоцию, она у
тебя застревает в теле. Те, кто видят,
они видят их
>> в виде, ну, какой-то жабы, ещё тому
подобное. Им кажется, что это там, а это
твоя эмоция. Как только ты её
высвободил, она ушла.
>> У. Ну всё, лады, а в каком-то разборе ты
говорил, что есть Таро, как бы
неправильное использование, есть
правильное использование Таро. Не, не
то, что неправильно, неправильно. Для
меня я для себя не использую. Мне я ээ
>> Ну ты прямо точно говорил, вот есть
неправильное использование Таро, вот
есть прямо правильное использование
Таро, если Таро использует правильно, то
это вроде как хорошо.
>> Такого не мог говорить.
>> То есть карты Тарома тоже, да? Или таро?
>> Слушайте, да в них нет ничего плохого.
>> У меня вообще до вот сейчас я уже на
таком мнении, что я в целом не воюю с
этой структурой, но
у меня просто ощущение, что нельзя
заглядывать в своё будущее.
>> Ну хорошо, ладно, я найду, постараюсь
найти. Я прямо помню эту историю. А,
смотри, ролик у тебя назывался с древсом
"Эзотерика эгрегор сатаны". Правильно?
То есть это твоё утверждение?
>> Нет, уже нет. Я я любитель
переобуваться. Я У меня меня швыряет
сильно. У меня
>> ай сначала меня швыряло сильно в
религию, потом сильно в эзотерику. Вот я
перебалансировался настолько, что я вот
нашёл какой-то баланс между верой в Бога
и вот этой всей штукой эзотерической.
Я считаю, что нужно выбирать что-то
странное какое-то. Сегодня мантры,
завтра молитвы, послезавтра, не знаю.
сатане косла козла зарезать. Ну типа
они, то есть это как бы ну странно.
Почему человек не может определиться? То
есть здесь нужно копать внутрь его
характера, почему он неопределённый? То
есть, ну понятное дело, кто-то обзовёт
это нью эйджем. И я просто книгу такую
писал из-за того, что я прямо понимал,
что очень много эзотерических практик
стали стали причиной моей депрессии,
которая у меня была. И меня очень хорошо
церковь обратно вырулила. И тут я сразу
такой стал воинствующий христианин, а
потом я подумал, что всё надо держать в
балансе.
хотите занимайтесь, заниматесь.
>> Сейчас ты уже эзотерику не осуждаешь.
>> Я вот нашёл какой-то баланс, потому что
это тоже позиция ребёнка. Кого-то
обвинять, винить, судить. Это вот я не
хочу таким быть. То есть если я кого-то
сужу, обвиняю, значит я до сих пор
маленький, не верю. У каждого есть
выбор. Делайте, пожалуйста. Но это с
древством этот подкаст. Он про что был?
Он был про то, что не забывай о Боге.
>> Ну да. То есть есть некие силы, от
которые от тебя не зависят.
>> Да. Да. То есть ты не не думай то, что
ты там себе визуализируешь и или что-то
сделаешь, что это тебе надо. И вот книгу
[фыркает] даже, которую я сейчас пишу, я
её передел. Она раньше называлась
"Эзотерика эгрегор сатаны". Я её
переделал на эзотерик не забывай о боге.
>> Круто.
>> А, да, у меня дальше был вопрос про то
есть ты как бы осуждаешь и не боишься
ли, так сказать, потом родиться
тарологам и астрологом? [смех]
>> А, да, я думаю, что я уже им был. Я типа
я думаю, я уже им был.
>> Ну, нормально. Ну да, я согласен, что,
так сказать, люди многие заигрались в
эту эзотерику, там возомнили себя вообще
всемогущими и отлетели, конечно, жёстко.
>> Это жёстко. И, ну, вообще, да, если
сказать, мой мой термин эзотерик, мне
нравится Сократовский, то есть экзо -
это внешний мир, э - это внутренний. Ну,
то есть по сути эзотерика - это всё про
внутренний мир. Вот его такое
определение вообще прикольное. То есть
по сути психология там это тоже
эзотерика.
>> И а вот я почему за эзотерику как бы
топлю, да? Я вообще с помощью неё выжил.
Я рассказывал это на разборе, там где у
меня была лютая сначала болезнь,
неизлечимая. Это был туберкулёз.
>> Угу.
>> Просто неизлечимая форма. Когда мне
сказали: "Мы, говорит, тебе сейчас
полёгкого уберём, будешь инвалидом 27
лет". Я говорю: "Не надо, ребята,
спасибо, я всё понял". То есть я начал
тогда читать Синельникова. Я хочу,
кстати, вот скоро с ним подкаст
записать. А, и говорю: "Ребята,
я понял урок, всё,
>> спасибо". И у меня через год просто нет
ничего. Мне сказали: "Ты умрёшь, если
сейчас ты не отрежешь".
>> Всё, год проходит, нет ничего. Ну вот
постараюсь забрать, может быть, эти
анализы прямо, чтобы в эфире показать,
если получится. Вот. Потому что я их
скриншотами,
>> я их не храню, да. Ну, ну есть у меня
там затемнение в лёгких, короче, через
год там его просто нет. Ну, в общем,
покажу. И я сейчас развиваю активно свой
клуб, где людям помогаю. В том числе то,
что называется, сейчас принято называть
эзотерикой. Хотя я это не называю
эзотерикой. Вильгельмрайх это называл
телесное энергетические практики. Он
это, ну, например, вот есть практика
рефлекс оргазма, то есть это мощная
практика, чтобы вообще поднять энергию в
теле. Она для лечения урологических
гинекологических заболеваний. И он, по
сути, заново открыл чакры.
Вильгельмрайх, то есть западный учёный,
который заново открыл чакры.
>> Угу.
>> Он назвал это просто мышечный панцирь, и
он расплетает этот мышечный панцирь с
помощью практик. И вот то, что я делаю,
это просто, ну, я [__] люди с
такими выходят глазами, выодушевлённые,
говорит: "Всё, я понял, что делать, я
понял, как решать мою ситуацию". Выходт
из депрессии, возвращают бывших, в
зависимости, сказать, просто отлетают за
ненадобностью. То есть X2 по доходу,
девочка отпахала чувство вины, просто X2
по доходу.
>> То есть поэтому, друзья, да, кому
интересно, актуальны эти темы, ссылочка
будет на клуб в описании. Вот. Едем
дальше. Аа вот, что касается денежной
энергии,
ты говоришь: "Вот, сделал там виниры,
эээ, купил то-то, купил то-то, потом
говоришь: "У меня на счету там 15.000
руб. Ну или там что-то 30.000, 40.000.
Вот у меня сейчас, говоришь, на карте
там что-то 40.000. То есть у меня всё
вложено там, всё везде". Вот мне
интересно, у тебя как бы капитал какой?
Вот именно вот свой личный капитал?
>> Ну, он небольшой вообще. Ну, несколько
миллионов рублей небольшой капитал.
А основные деньги у меня венчерные. То
есть у меня все деньги я сейчас
реинвестирую в своё приложение
Близнецовое пламя. А я реинвестирую их в
ещё одно приложение. Мы разрабатываем. Я
не я, кто на меня подписан там в телеге,
я потом там анонсирую. То есть мы делаем
социальную сети, не знаю, пойдёт она или
не пойдёт. То есть я и постоянно
реинвестирую. А деньги, которые я
откладываю, я откладываю, опять же,
говорю, себе в будущее по чуть-чуть на
ОФЗ. У меня там буквально, ну, может
быть, не знаю, э, чуть-чуть больше,
где-то 1,5 млн сейчас, э, ну, я себе
откладываю на пенсию. То есть я примерно
понимаю, что у меня есть стратегия там
тысяч по 20, 30, 40, 50 в месяц
откладывать, чтобы потом лет через 15
оттуда вытащить там. Ну не знаю, я я
плюс-минус там, не знаю, может, миллион
долларов, ну, например. То есть с учётом
сложного процента, с учётом, что, может
быть, иногда я больше доложу, может
быть, там где-то заработаю там, не знаю,
сразу, мне такое бывало, что я там 1.300
мог докладывать, у меня нет большого
капитала, но всё реинвестируется в
бизнесы, потому что я сейчас пока
молодой, я всё как бы сею семена, и я
пробую очень много бизнесов и очень
много я прогораю. Э и это с точки зрения
западной психологии, именно
бизнес-школы, это правильно, потому что
чем больше тебе ошибок, тем вероятнее,
что что-то одно выстрелит. То есть в
венчерных инвестициях есть такое
понятие, как спрейпрей. Тем более, когда
я как что-то даже затеваю, кто-то
устраивается на работу, люди получают
зарплаты, это всё равно польза. То есть
я понимаю, что всё равно так или иначе
платятся налоги, люди зарабатывают, ну,
как бы для меня это хорошо. То есть
капитала у меня как такого большого
нету, но я потихоньку себе вот
откладываю, как я говорил, пенсию, да,
то есть чтобы там, допустим, мне там
будет уже, не знаю, лет 70, например,
да, чтобы я мог не работать. До до 70
лет я точно там планирую работать,
что-то писать. Также я очень сильно
инвестирую деньги на, например, в
написание книг. То есть я нанимаю себе
людей, которые меня редактируют, те
книги, которые я пишу, потому что книги
они в будущем приносят хорошие деньги.
То есть они вот сейчас я, допустим, там
могу у меня все книги, все четыре книги,
бестселлеры,
>> стратегия, короче,
>> да. И, допустим, я там в квартал
вытаскиваю 200-300.000 за книги, но
представляешь, я потом напишу 10 книг.
Сейчас я хочу открыть своё издательство
за рубежом, чтобы продавать ещё на
зарубежную аудиторию. То есть я в себе
выстраиваю источники заработка как бы
сейчас вот как бы таким вот венчерным
инвестированием таким.
Вот. А с самого капитала именно
какого-то, чтобы я что-то отложил, я не
вижу смысла, потому что я живу сейчас. И
вот, например, я скопил денег на
фондовом рынке, да, я сделал зубы.
Сейчас вот я, допустим, хочу машину
купить, и я понимаю, что вот сейчас, э,
биткоин упал, я жене сказал: "Мы хотим
купить машину, давай скупим через
биткои". Вот он сейчас там был 82.000,
положим, вытащим. То есть я должна быть
цель какая-то, а пенсионная вот эта
стратегия у меня у меня есть. Да. А ты
считаешь, имеешь право, когда вот ты, у
тебя там пара миллионов, ну, как бы
учить людей на финансовые темы?
>> А, конечно, имею право, потому что у
меня-то пару миллионов живых денег. Ты
подумай, сколько у меня денег вложено.
Это так то есть вот, допустим, когда вот
считают состояние Илона Маска, например,
ты думаешь, у него считается, сколько у
него на счету лежит, у него на счету
также, может быть, на карточке там, не
знаю, 1.000 баксов лежит. У меня все
деньги раскинуты. В этом-то и прикол. То
есть я очень много бизнес-проектов
держу. Ну, то есть оно всё растёт, как
бы, да, и на этом ты опираешься, что вот
я как бы у меня всё прёт, я понял, как
всё устроено, да.
>> А погнали дальше. У нас прямо время,
время, время, Пётр, постараемся прямо
это блицам. В одном из эфиров ты
говорил, что людям надо перестать бегать
за морковкой, как ослик, да, и многим
надо просто вот жить, как живёшь, да.
Вот как понять,
>> прямо быстро вот бежать за морковкой или
остаться и возрадоваться тому, что
имеешь?
Когда ты остановишься и возрадуешься
тому, что имеешь, у тебя у тебя появятся
силы бежать за правильной морковкой.
>> Потому что та морковка, за которой ты
бежишь, если ты её не можешь догнать,
значит это неправильная морковка.
>> Ну то есть кто малым недоволен, большого
не достоин. Поговорка
>> славянс. Всё круто, согласен. А как
думаешь, в чём секрет твоего успеха
помимо жены? Ты каждый эфир начинаешь
или подкаст за благодарности жене.
Помимо жены и твоих практик дневника?
>> Это вера в Бога
>> исключительно.
То есть Бог всё-таки помогает.
>> Нет, не только он и ведёт тебя. То есть
только он и всё.
>> А вот смотри, вопрос такой: почему люди
выбирают именно твои курсы?
>> Я не продаю курсы.
>> Ну в клубе же продаёшь?
>> Нет.
>> Ну то есть в клубе они у тебя бесплатно
выложены.
>> Там нет курсов. Там единственное, что
есть, я сделал как подарок людям, кто в
закрытой телеге сидит, кто 3 месяца
сидит. Это как бонус. Я им даю по по
финансовой грамотности, типа про
инвестиции, и тому подобное.
>> А то есть вот твой курс трансформации
личности. Ну, мы тоже хотим его залить в
архив туда, но мы думаем ещё, как это
сделать. То есть сейчас нельзя у меня не
купить никакой курс.
>> Я был я искушался очень сильно залить
курсы в закрытый Telegram-канал, но
тогда я был бы обманщиком.
>> У меня только приложение. Ээ,
>> ну то есть, ну, всё равно как бы так или
иначе это опосредованная продажа. Ну,
как параллельный импорт, то есть,
>> ну, вот так, если посмотреть свысока,
кажется, что да, типа, ну, как бы я не
продаю, я не говорю, что там вот в
супиклуб там курс.
То есть на самом деле в клубе это мои
подкасты допконтент,
>> и люди туда вступают, они там слушают
типа там часдва эти подкасты, а это как
не знаю, как сказать. То есть ты уже
этот был у тебя курс, вот я сежу, куда
его деть, лучше хочешь похудеть. Мы
говорим там, ну, если вам по кайф,
пройдите. То есть когда идёт продажа
закрытого Telegram-канала, я не говорю,
что там курсы. То есть это, если бы я
говорил, это была бы хитрая продажа, то
то да.
>> У Лады. А чем, как ты считаешь, вот
пусть Ну как, ладно, они есть курсы. Вот
чем ты считаешь объективно твои курсы
лучше, чем, например, работа с
дипломированными психологами? Вот кроме
вот твоей уверенности, харизмы, вот что
ещё, чем ты считаешь объективно, а не
лучше? Ну потому что, мне кажется, я на
просторах интернета единственный человек
с результатом до после.
>> Сильное заявление.
Проверять я его, конечно, не буду.
>> Ну, типа обычно кто что-то вещает, вот
он, ну, вот он такой был, есть и будет,
а я был жирный алкоголик, наркоман, при
смерти, в депрессии. Вот. Ну это же всё
задокументировано, фотографии там или
там выступления мои ещё, когда я на
Первом канале выступал. Типа это всё
есть. И люди смотрят, они говорят: "Вот
этот человек, он спивался, он торчал, он
нюхал, он курил. Вот он вот, вот там же
фотки, я не знаю, если найдёшь,
посмотри,
>> а у тебя просто диплом." Короче, у тебя
результат.
>> Ну я же не говорю, что диплом хуже. Я
говорю о том, что я это прошёл и я это я
оттуда выкоропкался. Я говорю: "Ребят,
кто хочет бросить пить, курить, я
расскажу. Кто хочет как-то к Богу
приблизиться, я могу подсказать". Ну я
же, ну я не как типа там священник, да,
какой-то. Я имею в виду, что я наоборот
скажу: "Пйди в церковь". Ещё тому
подобное, кто в депрессии. Я это прошёл,
говорю: "Ребята, я вам помогу". То есть
потому что не потому, что у меня лучше
или ещё тому подобное. Люди идут, потому
что видят, что я сделал. Обычно человек
что-то вещает. Вот ты говоришь,
например, ты, у тебя был туберкулёз, из
туберкулёза нету. Ну это же классный
кейс.
>> Ну я из депрессии, кстати, тоже вылазил
после развода. Точно так же. Понимаешь,
это же классный кейс. Ты говоришь:
"Ребята, я вот так-то так-то сделал, у
меня получилось".
>> А, кстати, я показываю, знаешь что
прикол? провожу прямые эфиры. Ну, ты,
кстати, в том числе меня вдохновил вот
на эти вот прямые эфиры. Я начал их
проводить.
>> И вначале обязательно люди спрашивают:
"Ты кто?"
>> "Вот ты кто?"
>> И вот ты понимаешь, для массового
сознания вот нужен диплом. Я в какой-то
момент положил рядом, говорю: "Ребята,
вот вам корочка". То есть они говорят:
"О, ну ладно, психолог". То есть у меня
есть диплом психолога, говорю,
официальный, государственный. А, ладно,
теперь вступлю в клуб. Если вот нет, ну,
ну, как бы так мыслят народ.
>> Нет, это правильно так мыслить. То есть
должен быть какой-то у тебя гарант твоих
знаний. Может, ты просто пришёл, ну,
типа там рассказывать это. Вот я когда
пытался похудеть, когда вот ещё тогда
весил тонну, я смотрел людей, которые
мне рассказывали, как похудеть. Я вообще
не понимал, почему они меня учат, если
они всегда были худые. Типа я вообще
сижу, думаю, что
>> это вообще бы и для меня тоже было
удивительно, когда меня учил худеть
человек.
>> Он дипломированный специалист, но он ээ
толстый. Я вообще сижу, думаю: "Ну
почему? Ну типа как ты можешь меня учить
этому?" Да, у нас в школе осознания было
[смех]
нутрициолог, вот такой он в это кресло
бы не уместился. Ну, нутрициолог. А,
>> ну это же созлоси странно.
>> Это очень странно. Ну, как знаешь, как я
говорю, наркодилеры очень часто не
употребляют сами то, что, так сказать,
вещают. Но иногда работает даже, да,
>> было круто, если бы. Ну, видишь, в чём
прикол? Было бы круто, если бы у меня
был диплом.
>> Ну, ладно, учись, что.
>> Ну, я думал пойти сейчас на психологию,
но просто я же вот у меня, знаешь, как
человек приходит ко мне, я же не
оказываю ему психологическую услугу. Я
просто вот он рассказывает, я говорю:
"Дружище, я там был, я вот так выбрался.
Вот тебе вот так, вот так делай". То
есть это я стараюсь не лезть, знаешь,
там в какие-то
>> Ну вон, ко мне отправляй, у меня есть
диплом. [смех]
>> А так дальше погнали уже потихонечку в
блок религии.
>> Угу.
>> Давай побыстрее его пройдём, ибо дальше
про отношения, про личные вопросы и, так
сказать, немножко вот на тему
близнецовых пломён поговорим. А ты
как-то говорил, что Россия страна
анахатная, на четвёртой чакре США,
Запад, то есть третья чакра, да, такая,
так сказать, воинственная. Вот в чём,
по-твоему, прям, не знаю, коротко ты
умеешь, коротко прямо, а отличие такого
российского пути от западного и от
восточного, да, и сбудутся ли
пророчества Матроны московской, старцев
святых о неком возрождении России?
Конечно,
Америка - это больше и третья, и вторая
чакра денежная именно достижения и тому
подобное. И у них идёт
антиколлективизация. То есть у них
каждый человек за себя. У нас мы все
едины. То есть у нас один умрёт за
другого.
>> Вот о чём я и говорю. Вот про историю
вот. То есть мы вот такие коллективисты,
да?
>> Да. И мы коллективисты, то есть. Да. И
именно поэтому западная цивилизация и
западная культура, она в моменте нас,
ну, как бы разбила. То есть правильно,
на самом деле, все говорят в
правительстве и и типа пропагандисты,
что типа это Запад он разрушает, он
реально разрушает. Но это не значит, что
он плохой. Мне очень нравится Америка.
Ну типа классно. Я не из этих, кто типа
там только чёрные и белые. Но отличие в
том, что мы коллекти, коллективизм, у
них индивидуализмы. И если ты в этой
стране живёшь по принципам
индивидуализма, ты тебе будет плохо. То
есть лучше думать о коллективизме,
>> возродится Россия.
>> Именно духовный будет здесь подъём.
Посмотри, какая вообще, ну, в России
идёт тенденция на это всё
>> круто. Ну всё, погнали дальше в религию.
Короче, вот мне, знаешь, такой образ
пришёл. А, вот мы религия про душу, всё,
да, там буддизм, там ислам, тут
христианство, там ещё 100- 500 каких-то
ответвлений от каждой, так сказать,
религии. И вот прилетает инопланетянин,
тут ему рассказывают, короче, вот тут
душу надо как-то спасать, то есть тут
грех, тут грех, везде грех, короче, и
надо спасать душу. А он вообще вот
только прилетел,
>> вообще не бельмес, и он прилетает,
говорит: "Как душу-то спасти?"
И вот ему говорят: "Тут христиане одно,
он там переплывает в Чёрное море, там
мусульмане". Он говорит: "Там, ну, тут
как бы многожёнство, грех, ну, всё
нельзя, да, туда переплывать". Говорит,
там наоборот, там четыре жены можно даже
хорошо. То есть тут говорят, например,
свинину там, зато говорят: "Ешь,
сказать, нормально можно сало там все
любят, а там всё грех". То есть,
соответственно,
воровство тоже вот судный процент - это
как форма воровства такого, знаешь,
мошенничества, полумошенничество.
>> Ты про ислам, да, что у них расто?
>> А у них оно запрещено. Да, да. Вгойги
это типа нормально. То есть и вот
инопланетянин такой, знаешь, он
растерялся, то есть приезжает к чукчам,
к ивенкам, там у них есть вообще
традиция свою жену подкладывать гостю,
знаешь, у них, ну, щедрые ребята,
добрые. То есть жена, ну, вот ложись,
давай, друг же, хороший, хороший
человек, не жалко.
>> То есть как понять, как выбрать эту
религию? То есть ты как-то говорил в
одном эфире по месту проживания, типа
вот где родился, там пригодился. А вот
если переехать хочется человек, ну, не
знаю, вот как выбрать ему. Вот вот вот
есть многообразие всех вот религий,
всего всего всего. Вот ему как для себя
понять или вот инопланетянину?
>> Ну, смотри, опять же, ты рождаешься в
определённой стране для определённых
уроков. То есть тебе то, что нужно
пройти, ты там и родишься. Я вот недавно
объяснял, почему в России православие.
Потому что у нас главный урок каждого
человека, который здесь рождается - это
признание корней. У нас каждая вторая
семья живёт без отца.
>> То есть здесь реально люди не ценят вот
это всё. И поэтому православие оно
почему консервативное? Потому что здесь
люди должны именно стать
консервативными, ценить семью, ценить
верность и тому подобное. Именно поэтому
здесь такая религия. А если человек
рождается с другими задачами, да, там он
появляется абсолютно в другом этносе, в
другой ментальности и другая религия для
него. Но если ты хочешь познать уже
общий смысл, общий смысл бытия, ты
просто начинаешь изучать всё, и изучение
всего рождает один-единственный истинный
смысл. Вот и всё. Поэтому правильной
нету. Есть та, которая подходит лично
тебе. А если человек хочет переехать, а
нужно смотреть, почему он хочет
переехать. Если он из-за обиды хочет
переехать, например, из России, он как
раз этот урок не прошёл, непринятие.
>> Вот у меня, знаешь, я долгое время
изучал религии, погружался, ну, как,
знаешь, я лютый конспиролог, я всегда,
а, ну, с какого-то, не знаю, лет с
дтитрёх я начинаю сомневаться вообще во
всём. То есть я закончил универ, всё,
так сказать, отдал, там, женился и начал
вот изучать вообще всё. То есть, а, а,
там, оказывается везде, так сказать,
подлоги. И вот в религиях я тоже нашёл
кучу подлогов, но я нашёл одно общее,
что объединяет абсолютно все религии.
Это принцип их построения.
>> И психологи это, кстати, давно поняли,
что очень большая база религиозная
строится именно на чувстве вины.
>> Угу.
>> На запретах. И очень много людей
страдают. Вот чем сильнее запрет, тем
сильнее изврат. Есть такая история,
>> конечно.
>> И очень много людей страдают от того,
что якобы знают, как правильно и как
должно быть. У них жёстко колбасит их
здоровье, психосоматика накрывает. И ко
мне такие люди приходят в клуб, я их
сначала немножко вот работаю на ресурс,
потом постепенно оживляю, чтобы они
вообще пришли в себя. То есть потом уже
там финансы, отношения восстанавливают,
то есть они просто вот никакие. То есть
у них там чувство вины, чувство вины, я
неправильный, я плохой, я плохой, грех,
грех, грех, и капец. Всё, он вот вот всё
энергетика падает. Соответственно, я
хочу быть хорошим, а чтобы мне стать
хорошим, мне надо стать чуть ли не
святым, а я не могу. И, блин, всё,
сломался, короче, биоробот.
>> Вот. И я сейчас как сказать, мне вот
записал одну практику на снижение
чувства вины, и я сейчас даю вот всем,
кто ко мне приходит на консультацию.
Кстати, у меня бесплатный консультации в
моём клубе. Сейчас безоплатно можно
получить мою консультацию в клубе. Ждём
вас, а, по ссылке в описании.
А, [вздыхает] погнали дальше.
>> Так, а вопрос-то в чём был?
>> Вопрос в чём был? Смотри, а чувство
вины. Ну, это просто мой комментарий. То
есть твой, ну, твой ответ про религию,
ты говоришь,
ну, как бы дал своё видение по тому, как
выбрать эту религию. А я говорю, что а
есть общий принцип построения религии, и
можно не обязательно вот даже эту
религию выбирать, потому что психология,
как ты говорил, и наука-то тоже религия.
Так ведь?
>> Конечно,
>> своя просто. Ну и всё. То есть кому
какая религия вот нравится больше, вот
выбирай. Я считаю, что не только по
месту как бы рождения, но ещё и ты вот
родился вот в одной семье, блин, и
чувствуешь, что вот как-то вот что-то не
то, а потом переезжает человек, вот ему
там хорошо оказывается где-то. Ну так
тоже бывает.
>> Не бывает, конечно. Я просто это базовый
принцип построения религии. Это не
базовый принцип построения. Это базовый
принцип понимания его. Это большинство
людей понимают через чувство вины. И это
нормально, потому что одному человеку,
например, проще не изменить жене, потому
что его накажет Бог, а не потому, что он
понимает законы вселе.
>> Потому он её любит, да? И не потому, что
он её любит, а потому, что Бог накажет.
Поэтому ему через чувство вины, когда он
будет выше на уровне сознания, у него
есть семь семь уровней принятия религии.
Первая религия из страха. Меня вот это
меня накажут. Второе уровень и стыда. То
есть, например, женщина разгульная, она
не будет разгуливать только потому, что
она будет стыдиться Бога. Третье - это
из долга. Религиозные фанатики, в
основном на третьем долг, а не надолгие.
Четвёртое, по любви. Ты уже в этой
религии просто потому что ты любишь, ты
никого не осуждаешь, ты никого не
судишь.
>> Большинство людей в страхе. Вот.
>> Ну так это не построение религии, это
это понимание религии. То есть у каждого
человека может быть семь уровней
понимания религии. И первый уровень из
страха. И когда мы там типа смотрим, вот
смотрите, все религии, они там типа этот
это так люди понимают. Я же
[откашливается] её так не понимаю. Я,
допустим, я вообще по-другому смотрю на
все религии.
>> Ну там есть также, как я вот рассказываю
на своих эфирах, там есть ну как бы
любой живой организм стремится
увернуться от опасного в сторону
полезного. Вот там страх прогноз
опасности, а здесь прогноз полезности,
соответственно. То есть, ну, амёба
уползает там в сторону света и воды, да,
где питательные вещества. И,
соответственно, человек также, то есть
он убегает оттуда, где страшно, туда,
где хорошо. Всё. И, соответственно, вот
здесь страх, там типа грех, не, а вот
здесь любовь, там всё, иди туда. И вот
мы такие, знаешь, ну, если так очень
упростить, так сказать, биологически мы
далеко не ушли вот от таких вот простых
организмов,
>> а для, так сказать, управления нам нужно
вот некий образ, да, к чему нам идти,
вот где там, сказать, как расти вот
духовно, да, вот это вот условно к
сердцу. А страх вот нас туда, ну, как бы
туда толкает. Вот как-то так. То есть и
вот, ну, многие там застревают в этом
страхе. И вот я говорю, я через чувство
вины людьми вот работаю там, которые
прямо застряли, утонули, короче, там
прямо жёстко. И там очень много, ну, у
меня после развода, помнишь, я тебе
рассказывал, там чувство вины до такого.
У меня просто живот просто у меня вот
такой. Я 7 дней ничего не могу есть, не
хочу, лежу на диване, у меня просто
чувство вины меня убивает, я хочу
умереть. Всё, я не справился. Я плохой,
плохой, плохой по всем фронтам.
Всё, говорит, умри.
>> [вздыхает][тяжело вздыхает]
>> подсознание. Ну, как-то вот выжил
благодаря, кстати, вот этой практике.
Угу.
>> А цитата патриарха Кирилла: "А
непротивление злу является
пособничеством убийству. Как относишься
к этой цитате?"
>> Да никак. Ну, ну он так сказал и сказал.
Ну что, что я сделаю?
>> Ну то есть ты что-то подержишь из того,
что
>> Ну, он выше меня. Как я могу его судить?
>> В этой иерархии
>> не не судить. Ну сам ты согласен с этим
ты же нет.
>> Да я я не знаю даже, как реагировать.
Ну, ну сказал и сказал. У меня просто у
меня есть в своей голове какой-то
внутренний компас, и меня я уже не
слушаю людей, понимаешь? Типа у меня,
ну, я понимаю, что зло есть. Я,
например, если мы говорим про Евангелие,
Христос вообще в Евангелит говорит: "Не
противьтесь злу". То есть я думаю, что
патриарх Ирил здесь не про это говорил.
Здесь разные вещи. Я думаю, Иисус
говорил это более в таких вещах, когда
ты видишь, что в мире что-то происходит,
например, на твой взгляд,
несправедливое. Мне кажется, что это всё
для кого-то нужно.
>> Не противьте зло. А тут же написано в
Ветхом Завете, например, наоборот: "Око
за око, зуб за зуб".
>> Ветхий Завет - это для тех людей. Те
люди, они ещё варвары были, им про
любовь нельзя было говорить.
>> Вот смотри. Ещё вопрос, да, кстати, по,
ну, нашей аудитории. То есть людей
шокировало. То есть вообще религия, она
же говорит: "Возлюби ближнего прежде
всего". Да.
>> Да.
>> То есть живи счастливо, люби ближнего и
такие вот, так сказать, любовь и так
далее транслирует. И вот когда мы
говорили с тобой про золотой миллиард,
вот сейчас у нас и позиции церкви, в
принципе, осуждает вот эту идеологию
золотого миллиарда, да, Путин часто про
это говорит. То есть, ну, мы как бы, ну,
по сути, и Россия воюет-то за вот то,
что вот западная концепции всех нагнуть,
колонизировать, да, и на них
паразитировать. То есть, а, мы как бы
вот не поддерживаем вот эту вот историю.
И причём золотой миллиард, он сейчас,
ну, всё чаще говорит, а это идея о том,
чтобы оставить вот некогою миллиард это
западные страны, а остальные будут
рабами и сократить ещё ненужных людей,
там, Бил Гейтс с его там всякими
программами. Так вот, а ты как бы очень
невнятно сказал, что люди подумали, что
ты поддерживаешь в принципе сокращение 7
млрд людей.
>> Да ничего я не поддержива. Ты как бы
типа духовный человек, короче, ты там
любишь, ну, предлагаешь возлюбить
ближнего и тут же как бы говоришь: "А,
типа, впишитесь в золотой миллиард". Вот
>> что там было конкретно конкретная цитату
мы
>> там конкретная цитата, ну, мы её
вставим. А, то есть, ну, ты можешь
вписаться в золотой миллиард. Вот такая
точно была цитата. Ты можешь вписаться в
золотой
>> миллиардр. Опять вот эта позиция мысли.
Какие-то элиты решили, что все будут
рабами и тому подобное. Это опять
позиция, что кто-то есть старше. И я
говорю: "Вот вникни в моё сознание. Сам
стать старшей те ты не будешь этого
бояться. Это не значит стать кем-то
крутым, и у тебя будут рабы. Это значит,
что твоя жизнь не зависит от решений
золотого миллиарда."
>> Нене, даже не про миллиард дело. Ну вот
смотри, сейчас, например, вот мы выходим
из студии, да, там кого-то, не знаю,
пинают ногами. Вот ты вступишься? Нет.
>> Причём здесь золотой миллиард?
>> Ну это позиция о том, [фыркает] вот
этого ближнему помоги или ближнего, так
сказать, пускай выживет сильнейший.
>> Нет, ну этото странный пример. Я просто
вызову полицию.
Ну, то есть это всё равно вписаться,
помочь.
>> Ну, я помогаю из той ответственности,
которая у меня есть.
>> Вот. Ну, это, понимаешь, это идея как
раз о том, что мы на какой стороне
находимся здесь, за кого. То есть,
>> а причём золотой миллиард кого-то без
>> смотри, золотой миллиард - это идея о
том, что Запад вообще хорошие ребята,
они колонизировали, они молодцы. Вот эти
страны колонии, мы в том числе мы
колонии,
>> так их колонизировали уже.
>> Мы колония Запада, то есть мы Россия
колония Запада. Мы, то есть они
метрополи, у них, смотри, есть ФРС
система, Федеральная резервная система,
у нас есть Центробанк. То есть все
Центробанки, когда ты видишь, у них есть
стабилизационный фонд, который всегда
находится в Федеральном резерве. Ты
знаешь, да, что наши деньги заморожены,
там 300 млрд, по-моему, то есть когда
началась война,
>> 300 млрд просто были заморожены, и они
идут на войну против нас.
>> То есть, ты понимаешь, да, это вообще
весёлое. То есть там, где есть
стабилизационный фонд и Центробанка, то
есть теперь ты знаешь, что это колония,
это не самостоятельное государство. И
они управляют через экономику. Они
выкачивают 90% ресурсов отсюда просто
бесплатно. Нам ещё кое-как Путин там
отвоевал чуть-чуть в начале дхтысячных,
чтобы что-то перепадало России. Сейчас
там идёт война жёсткая за эти вот, так
сказать, рынки. И страна-колония.
>> Так, а причём, что бьют кого-то на
улице? И вот история-то их в том, что мы
как бы поддерживаем эту позицию, что
надо сократить население, да и хер бы с
этими семью м миллиардами или, блин,
как-то вот я за людей, я люблю людей, не
знаю, я хочу им как-то помочь, как-то их
поддержать там, насколько могу.
>> Послушай, я просто не мыслю этими
категориями. Ты говоришь там, что они
там кого-то как я могу решить, кого
сократить, кого поддерживать? Опяржи,
да, я не поддерживаю, у меня нету, я на
меня не влияют эти структуры, ты
понимаешь? Я я делаю так, чтобы в своей
жизни я принимал решениние и чтобы чтобы
там не придумали эти ребята, я сделаю
так, чтобы я не зависел от них решения.
>> Я не говорю, что нужно сократить
население. Я что, дурак, что ли? Ну ты
прикинь, реально есть люди, которые
сидят и на полном серьёзе отдают своё
внимание про то, что там будет золотой
миллиард, и им страшно.
>> Да боя.
>> Ну подумайте о том, как как попасть в
золотой миллиард.
>> Выходи там.
Ну, подумайте о том, как как попасть в
золотой миллиард
>> или я не говорю, что нужно, не знаю, там
не сокращать его. Я просто у меня есть
зона ответственности в моей жизни. Меня
этот решение этого золотого миллиарда,
оно не влияет. Есть люди, элиты.
>> Нет, влиять не влияет - это другой
вопрос. Как ты относишься? Вот, грубо
говоря, издали указ о том, что убить
моние не имеет в
>> убить там таких-то людей.
>> Вот это мнение, которое,
>> ну, смотри, про пенсию. У тебя же есть
мнение. Ну, понятное дело, потому что я,
у меня есть мнение, потому что я делаю
это так, как мне будет в ответственность
только на мне. То есть я говорю, я выбл
такой путь, я не надеюсь на пенсию, я
делаю себе. И поэтому я тебе говорю своё
мнение, как я поступаю в этой ситуации.
Я не говорю, кто там прав в этой пенсии,
кто не прав. Ещё говорю, как я делаю.
Это это моё мнение. В этой ситуации моё
мнение, что меня вообще не должно
колыхать этот миллиард. То есть у меня в
моей голове нету людей, от которых
зависит моя жизнь. Понимаешь? То есть ты
говоришь, эти люди примут решение за Они
не могут про меня принять решение.
>> Смотри, ты уже принял, на самом деле,
ты, когда ты на Донбасс отправил
гуманитарку,
>> ты, в принципе, уже, ну, обозначил свою
сторону, что ты здесь и что мы, по сути,
воюем вот против этой истории западной
такой. А у нас даже стратегия войны
разная, понимаешь, да. Они ставят,
например, в жилом районе пушку, чтобы
наши туда не могли попасть на втором, на
третьем этаже жилого дома и хреначат по
нашим войскам. Наши ответить не могут,
понимаешь? Да. То есть наши так не
могут. То есть они, ну, как знаешь, там
есть мем такой, вот сейчас вставим. То
есть этот за коляску, ну, то есть тут
мать с коляской, да, и этот стреляет как
бы прикрываясь коляской, а этот,
наоборот, наш защищает эту коляску,
понимаешь? То есть вот разные немножко у
нас подходы. Я вот об этом, я вот об
этом. Ну хорошо, ладно, проехали.
>> А так тут у нас э вот эти вот
интересные, кстати, блин, вопросы про
религию, но у нас остался с тобой час.
Мм. Ну, давай вот это возьмём. Вопрос
про судный процент мы обещали. Давай про
судный процент. Смотри, а ты знаешь,
Иисус выгнал фарисеев, книжников
>> из церкви, да, чтобы, так сказать,
церкви,
>> ну, торгашей, грубо говоря, выгнал.
Соответственно, в Коране запрещён судный
процент.
>> Угу.
>> Аа ты как думаешь, вот Иисус бы одобрил
вообще вот эту всю систему вкладов,
кредитов нашу вообще? Как?
>> Да я никак не думаю. Ты понимаешь, в чём
прикол? У меня есть ответственность за
свою жизнь, и я просто решаю для себя,
беру я его или не беру. У меня не У меня
нет авторитета. Для меня писание
Евангелия авторитет, но я имею в виду,
что для меня нет авторитета вот этого
вымышленного. А как бы сказал Иисус или
ещё что-то, вот у меня есть жизнь.
>> Вымышленный, ты же вроде опираешься на
его цитат, ты людей ведёшь туда. Ось я
опираюсь и я в разделе денег, как вот
надеюсь на Бога. То есть да, я хочу их
зарабатывать, чтобы моя жена жила, но я
на них не надеюсь. Понимаешь, в чём
прикол? И поэтому у меня вопрос там об
этом судном проценте, что тому подобное.
Он у меня не стоит даже в голове. Блин,
а я не могу понять. Вот смотри, ты
продвигаешь Евангелие, ты двигаешь
людей. Вот условно вот это святое
Писание, которое не менялось, что ценно.
Кстати, вот Коран гордится тем, что оно
не переписывалось, там невозможно его
переписать. Ну, Библию там как-то
переписывали, там и апокрифы какие-то
изъяли. То есть
>> вот это некая незыблемая истина, да? Вот
я говорю, что это незыблимая истина. Это
то, что тебе здесь, вот ты здесь живёшь,
вот ты здесь родился, это то, что тебе
поможет бог. Мы опираемся на это как вот
какое-то светлое будущее. Мы куда-то
хотим. Вот. Вот делай так, получишь
сказать светлое будущее. Хорошо. Но
смотри, если я вот это беру, а это я
типа не хочу видеть, то есть я,
получается, не последователен в этих вот
в следовании этому пути Евангелия.
>> Ну почему?
>> Ну смотри, я вот это я взял, а это я
такой не согласен. Ну смотри, в этом-то
и есть смысл. А как ты истину познаешь,
если ты не будешь сомневаться? Я,
допустим, каждое то, что я прочитываю, я
передумываю, продумываю, как это, что
это. Например, в Евангелии вообще очень
м что касается денег, там, если
неправильно понимать, то деньги вообще
там зло и тому подобное. То есть многие
люди там, когда читают фразу, что трудно
богатому войти в царствие божие, то есть
для тебя, если ты в Евангелии, если ты в
христианстве, то то богатым быть плохо,
да, ты в рай не попадёшь. Но там же
строчкой ниже, я не помню в каком,
по-моему, от Матфея, он уточняет трудно
надеющемуся, понимаешь? Том надеющемуся.
То есть если ты надеешься и то есть
какие-то вещи есть Евангелия, да, там,
например, Христос говорит, что лучше
вообще от секса, например,
воздерживаться, лучше быть с копцом от
рождения либо ради царствия божие, да?
То есть мне, допустим, вот я с там с
женой своей живу, мне, ну, вот я я не
хочу воздерживаться от секса, хотя Иисус
это впрямую говорит, но церковь говорит,
что нормально иметь жену свою, потому
что ве в Ветхом Завете написано. То есть
ты так или иначе будешь принимать
что-то, что-то отвергать, в тебе будет
рождаться истина. То есть ты должен
что-то, ты должен осмысливать, смотреть,
если ты только будешь вот так вот всё
принимать, типа вот прямо полностью, у
тебя в какой-то момент шайба стукнется,
потому что какие-то жизненные моменты
уже поменялись.
>> Слушай, а как понять, что принимать, а
что нет? Вот тут, говорит, Библия, вот
принимай, а тут ты не принимаешь,
говорит, тебе святой отец настоятель
скажет: "А что ты вот это принял, а это
не принял? Значит, ты не последо,
значит, ты не христианин". Значит, как
ты можешь себя называть христианином?
>> Я послушаю, что скажет святой отец. Я
послушаю, что скажут богословы, экзеты.
Я послушаю, что я сам скажу. Я послушаю,
что скажут умные ребята. Из этого всего
у меня родится истина. Понимаешь, в чём
прикол? Вот.
>> Ну то есть само, ну, то есть получается
завтра ты можешь, в принципе, на тему
христианства тоже передумать вообще,
>> да? Это не передумать, это называется
развитие мышления. То есть ты каждый раз
у тебя развивается что-то, у тебя очень
много вещей меняется в голове. Но опять
же говорю, у меня моя жизненная позиция,
это, наверное, ну, около половины там
плюс плюс-минус 10% - это всё, что
основно на Евангелии. Что, что там
самого-то основное? Там Нагорная
проповедь, то есть относись к другим как
хочешь относились к тебе. Люби, не, не
кради, там, не убивай. Ну, короче,
обычная тема.
>> Хорошо, не убивай. Давай так. Давай от
этой не по
кого-то убивают, ты говоришь: "Надо
вмешаться". Да? То есть в твоей картине
мира, то есть ну нельзя так оставлять.
То есть, ну, всё-таки надо как-то вот
этому злу сопротивляться.
>> Нет, смотри, если кого-то убивают, вот
если что-то происходит, я понимаю, что
на это есть воля Господа. Смотри, есть
позиция, так сказать, вообще дзэн, меня
нету, так сказать, там оно всё
происходит.
>> Ну, если меня сюда послали, например,
да, и я в этой ситуации оказался, я
спрошу себе, что что Бог хочет от меня,
чтобы я здесь сделал. Опять же говорю, я
сделаю то, что я могу. Я вызову полицию,
но я не буду рисковать. У меня в детстве
была интересная ситуация. У меня
родственника убили за то, что он
вступился за женщину в магазине, его
зарезали просто там же, понимаешь? То
есть вопрос я он я должен с собой
рисковать. У меня есть жена, у меня есть
родители, но я не оставлю человека в
беде. Я вызову полицию, придут люди, чья
ответственность тут есть. Спасибо, что
ты рассказал. Знаешь, вот как, знаешь,
мне очень нравится с тобой общение,
потому что у нас, ну, как бы где-то
схожие такие стратегии выживания,
знаешь, где-то там я спринтер, ты там
спринтер, где-то мы марафон смеш, а
где-то ты там вообще конкретно
по-другому, короче, вообще мыслишь и я.
И то есть вот у тебя получается породу,
э, кто-то так сделал, это у тебя
записалось, что не надо так делать, а у
меня когда-то спасали мои, наверное,
деды, прадеды там кого-то, и это их
спасло, и они выжили благодаря этому. И
поэтому у меня идея о том, что надо
тотально включаться, вовлекаться, надо
людей вот спасать, вытаскивать,
помогать. У
>> а у тебя как бы идея, ну вот как бы
>> нет, я я помогу в рамках той
ответственности, которая у меня есть,
понимаешь? Чем
>> всё? Ну и я также. А в общем, смотри,
получается, можно, в принципе, быть
непоследовательным в религии и считаться
вот, ну, можно сказать, христианином.
>> Ну, мне священник скажет, что я не
христианин. Он мне скажет, что я там
верю в прошлое жизни и тому подобное. Но
у меня вос Христос прилзать
как в целом жить. Ну, то есть жить,
чтобы наоборот не страдать, понимаешь?
Как бы я я уважаю церковь, я хожу в
церковь, я хожу на богослужение, я могу
причаститься. То есть мне вообще в кайф.
Мы приложение сделали по изучению
Евангелия.
>> Слушай, ну а вольная интерпретация
Евангелия - это разве не ересь?
>> Ну это ересь со стороны, если это будет
церковь. Но какая-то вольная
интерпретация. Я всё равно так или иначе
то, что я там говорю, оно плюс-минус
одинаково. Я ничего, ну что другое? То
есть про перерождение, например, тоже
если я говорю там какое-то,
>> ну, есть вот,
>> ну, вольная интерпретация в чём именно?
То есть оно вот у меня,
>> смотри, есть сейчас ну есть Ветхий
Завет, где говорит там зуб за зуб, там
для той наркости есть вот возлюби
ближнего, да? Вот,
>> ну, так Иисус как говорит, вам говорили,
вот я тебя цитирую, вам говорили око за
око, зуб за зуб, а я говорю молись за
проклинающего вас, да? То есть он даёт
Новый Завет, то есть то человечество,
тот тот уровень развития. Он же там даже
говорит, Моисей дал вам по мягкосердечю
законы эти, что вы можете разводиться.
То есть
>> вот я сейчас хочу собрать вот эти темки.
Пётр, сейчас попробуй сейчас прямо, я не
знаю, услышь меня. Хочу, чтобы ты меня
сейчас услышал.
>> Важно. То есть как будто история про
Ветхий Завет это вот условно
третьечакровая, первочакровая какая-то
история жёсткая там, жестокая.
>> Эта история какая-то сердечная. И здесь
история, что Иисус он как раз-таки был
против мошенников. Он был против вот
этого всего геноцида убийств. И я к
тому, что есть Евангелие, например,
которые, а, ну, пытаются люди туда
стремиться, да, и застав дурака Богу
молиться, лоб расшибёт. А есть,
например, советские люди, которые вообще
по сути жили по Евангелию. Они не знали
вообще про христианство, но они, по
сути, жили по всем Божьим заповедям. То
есть не обязательно изучать Евангелие,
чтобы быть с Богом. То есть можно,
например, если ты поддерживаешь,
например, мошенников, поддерживаешь
убийц, типа говоришь: "Да нормально, бог
там всё разрулит", да? А тут же есть,
например, история, что, ну, это такой же
грех, поддержка мошенников и убийц,
понимаешь? То есть и здесь такой некий
водораздел. Человек для себя выбирает
вот некую дзен философию, где а всё
происходит по воле Бога, и там кого-то
убили и кого-то ворвали. Я тут не при
делах. А здесь, а здесь история, что ты
потворствуй убийству, ты потворствуй
мошенничеству, ты создаёшь это. И мне
очень близка вот эта история, кстати,
евангельская
>> Иисуса, который говорит, что смотри, ты
это всё делаешь. Смотри, ты грешишь,
дурак, ты создаёшь. То есть ты
поддерживай вот эту срань, ты её
создаёшь, ты поддерживай вот это вот всё
растовщичество, ты её создаёшь. Го. Ты
же говоришь про людей, которые
непосредственно в этой штуке, ну,
которые там непосредственно в ней
участвуют.
>> Так мы и участвуем
>> в чём?
А, ну смотри, я тебе не говорю, что ты
плохой. У меня тоже деньги на вкладах. И
я говорю, что мы сейчас, ну, как будто
живём в последние времена, и мы
действительно уже в какой-то степени
осатонели. Все это в какой-то степени. И
вот эти все вклады, это вся денежная
финансовая система, ну, мы же держим
деньги на вкладах, а их же берут в
кредит. И получается, ты часть этой
системы, получается, ты её не то чтобы
одобряешь, ты ещё и в ней. У тышься в
ней напрямую и ещё и её, собственно,
кормишь,
>> понимаешь? У меня не зло, у меня их
много, я люблю их, понимаешь? Но не зло,
но понимание есть, что я часть этой
системы, и я создаю, собственно, эту
хрень,
ну, растовщичество вот это, это же
мошенничество. Есть фильм, смотри, для
зрителей, чтобы глубже было понимание.
Хочу весь мир и ещё 5%.
>> Шикарный фильм. Нарамоле, кстати, он
когда-то набрал там 5 млн просмотров.
Шикарный ролик про то, как вот
глобалисты, ростовщики, торгаши просто
нагнули весь мир через судный процент.
Всё. И мы сейчас вот получается рабы
транснациональщиков. Есть, смотри, а
евреи, у которых судный процент
запрещён, они говорят: "Мы своим в
займы, в кредиты не даём и не берём". У
них есть цитата из Ветхого Завета:
"Брату своему не давай деньги в рост, а
иноземцу давай деньги в рост, и будешь
господствовать над многими народами, а
они над тобой не будут господствовать".
Всё. И корпорация Black Roрок, там
евреи, евреи, евреи, и она как бы
владеет там чуть ли не там 30% вообще
мировых ресурсов.
>> То есть опять есть какие-то злые дяди
наверху, которые
>> они не злые, они просто живут по другой
концепции.
>> Какая тебе разница, как они живут? Ну,
понимаешь, у меня сказать, я познаю мир,
мне интересно, как он устроен.
>> Ну, смотри, мои мои деньги лежат на на
ОФЗ, да, и ко мне приходит государство,
говорит: "Дай мне в долг".
>> Типа я на эти деньги буду вот как я
думаю. Ты думаешь, что там люди будут
страдать, а я как это вижу? На эти
деньги государство будет развиваться. Мы
за это тебе дадим больше через 15 лет.
>> Не, я себя и оправдать могу и обвинить.
Понимаешь, как это тоже.
>> А за что ты себя винишь? Подождите, ты
тебе приходит госу.
>> Смотри, я вклад держу. У меня несколько
вкладов, и
>> человек с помощью того, что у меня в
банке лежат вклады, берёт кредит.
>> Он берёт кредит, потому что он [__]
Блин, я себе просто дал слово не
осуждать,
а не потому, что он, понимаешь,
>> еслит,
если мы глубже копнём, то если не будет
тех, кто держит вклады банки, банк
сдохнет,
>> сдохнет вся экономическая система
>> и не будет тех, кто брать кредиты будет.
>> Ты берёшь, понимаеш, ты
>> я сейчас поясню про дебила, про кого я
говорил. Ты переживаешь за людей,
которые закредитованы. Им плохо. Им
плохо не потому, что ты там вклад
открыл. Им плохо потому, что у них нет
финансовой грамотности. Не потому, что
Никита открыл вклад, а потому, что это
его выбор совершать дебильные поступки,
идти брать микрозаймы на айфоне.
>> Нету твоего тут ничего участвовать в
этом. Ты, у тебя есть контракт, тебе
говорят: "Я что дальше не с этими
деньгами? Они на эти же деньги".
>> Сейчас, сейчас, сейчас, Пётр, я разовью
тему. Смотри, я тогда могу, получается,
есть мошенники, которые сейчас конкретно
обкрадывают людей. Я как-то ехал с одним
моим приятелем, он говорит: "Ну, я вот
участвую в схеме, вот на Авито мне
звонят, просят квартиру, я сдаю, смотри,
я сдаю".
>> Он считает, что он вообще не виноват. Я,
говорит, просто мне звонят, я им
скидываю ссылку на вот эти квартиры, мне
платят 2.000, а квартиру он им не
отдаёт,
>> он в схеме.
>> И он говорит: "Я не виноват". Я говою:
"Чувак, это ты конкретно создаёшь, ты
обманываешь людей".
>> Он конкретно создаёт. Ну,
>> Никит, если бы ты сидел я также, смотри,
а я если бы инвестировал вот в эту
компанию, которая обманывает людей, я бы
был соучастником.
>> Ну, конечно.
>> И также бы меня и судили. И,
соответственно, я, ну, я участник вот
этой мошеннической системы, по сути, мы
все такие.
>> Но если у тебя вот эта денежная система
мошенническая, то тогда всё продай, живи
без денег,
>> как, собственно, учил Иисус.
>> Ну, [смех] он не этому учил. Он учил, он
когда говорил: "Продай своё учение,
следуй за мной", он говорил о том, что
ты должен Бога и смысл жизни поставить
на первое место. Тот парень, он надеялся
на своё богатство. Он очень многим людям
не говорил продавать. У Христа в
окружении было очень много богатых
людей. Он только одному человеку сказал:
"Продай своё имущество, потому что он к
нему был привязан. Он говорил, что ты
должен возненавидеть мать отца своего".
Смотри, ты должен вообще не думать, что
люди совершают дебильные поступки, беря
эти кредиты. Это их ответственность.
>> Ну вот моя ответственность вкла Ну
смотри, моя ответственность в чём? Я
вложу, например, в инвестиции
какого-нибудь экопродукции какой-нибудь,
да, то, что людей возвышает, то, что
людей, ну, делает людьми, да? Или я могу
вложить по вот какую-то
полумошенническую серую схемку по обману
пенсионеров. То есть я куда свои деньги
инвестирую? Я вниманием что создаю, что
я умножаю в этом мире. Вот я к этому,
понимаешь? Я к тому, что вот куда
внимание, туда энергия. Баян, конечно,
но вот как, говорит, понять, ты
капиталист или ты социалист? Вот когда у
тебя в детстве просили деньги на обед, у
>> ну твой друг просит тебя деньги на обед,
>> ты ему ну или просто обед. Ты ему дашь
обед или дашь ему деньги под проценты?
>> Я ему просто дам денег. Он же мой друг.
>> Всё. Точка. [смех]
>> Какой процент? Нет, послушай про про
этот про растовщичество. Любой кредит -
это сделка с дьяволом. Любой кредит -
это сделка с дьяволом, если ты хочешь
такое услышать.
>> Ну, если вклад, тогда тоже сделка с
дьяволом.
>> Нет, ты же вклад ты даёшь в дом.
>> Так ты в систему ростовщичества
вкладываешь.
>> Послушай, во-первых, я вкладываю в ОФЗ,
в акции и компании, которые мне
интересны.
>> Такой же вклад. Почему я даю, как я
думаю, я люблю государство, я даю ему
деньги,
>> оно там прокручивает через банки, через
100, 500 каких-то полухрен поймических
схем.
>> Какая разница? У меня договор я уже не
думаю. То есть, смотри, я как бы
инвестировал, вы, говорит, мне говорят,
там 30% мы тебе Никитос дадим. А что вы
там делаете? Мне насрать. Ну это же ты
выбрал не въехать в эту ту как бы серую
схему, которую тебе говорят: "30% типа
да я получил и всё". А на чём эти 30%
сделано? Это не важно дело. Я как думаю,
если государство берёт ОФЗ у меня в
долг, я думаю, что это идёт на
благоустройство страны, на защиту
государства. Помаешь, у меня у меня
светлая полоса, кто куда смотрит. Когда
я инвестирую ВКонтакте, и я у меня очень
много акций ВКонтакте, я инвестирую в
то, чтобы наши соцсети.
>> Не, ну я согласен с тобой, знаешь, что
выгодно думать, как говорит Ситников,
кстати, если даже это не так, выгодно
так думать. То есть, если даже это не
так, то есть выгодно думать, что я
инвестирую, допустим, вклад и люди
берут, проходят карму. То есть они
должны познать вот этот вот долги, вот
зашкварит, скажи это не твоя
ответственность уже.
>> Ну просто смотри, прикол в том, что я не
беру кредиты. Для меня у меня были
кредиты, я понимаю, что это дебилизм.
Кредит может брать человеку только тот,
у которого есть чем отдать.
>> Пётр, я хочу про ответственность. Мы
сейчас капец. Мы сейчас просто мы не
успеваем. А, смотри, про лже
свидетельство. Ты говорил: "Не
свидетельствуй", да, если не видишь так
же ясно, как видишь,
>> да, в исламе. Ты с этим согласен? Нет.
>> Ну это значит ты, когда ты прямо
выносишь суждение, например, вот ты
видишь человека и ты говоришь там, он,
например, инфациган, он берёт кредит,
потому что он [__]
>> Да. Ты видел, что он сделал, что он
прошёл, сколько рабочих мест он сказдал,
сколько денег. Вот пока пока не увидишь,
пока не не в поймаешь его за руку, тогда
свидетельствуй. Угу.
>> Угу. Смотри, просто вот ясность про
ясность. Вот там истории говорят
христианстве тыся лет. Вот смотри, а
есть гравюры, их десятки, сотни, они в
музеях лежат. Вот на церквях XVI век там
крестов нету. То есть там какие-то три
ноги, какие-то странные символы.
>> Угу.
>> А вот
>> вот такие вот. Это тебе как? То есть вот
на куполе какая-то вот параболическая
антенна. Так.
>> И их сотни. Их сотни. Вот тут нет ни
одного креста. То есть эта гравюра
реально лежит в музее, понимаешь? Все
можно проверить. Кое-где ещё остались
вот такие странные кресты очень странных
форм.
>> Вот такие. Вот такие. Их очень много.
>> Угу.
>> То есть, э, ну вот, то есть тут нет
крестов. И что?
>> Ну, есть храм во Владимире, как
Дмитровский собор. Во, вспомнил. И там
нарисован даждь Бог на церкви. Прямо
птичка - это символ дождь бога. Это как
бы как бы язычество. И вопрос вот мы
когда понимать пытаемся христианство и
видя вот это всё, вот вообще мы вообще
что-то знаем о христианстве или вот вот
или вот мы вообще просто что-то
фантазируем?
>> Ну послушайте, ну я как я вот читаю,
допустим, писание христианское, да, для
меня важны смыслы, понимаешь? Для меня
неважно, какие там были кресты в X веке,
были они, не были. Я ищу смысл. Вот бы
жил Христос, как он говорил жить. Я ищу
это. Я не Я не ищу символики. Кто-то
говорит, что я не жил. Всё есть. Да,
>> даже если не жил, смысл- это книги
классный. Например, это всё выдумка.
Какой бомбический смысл? Ты читаешь,
хочешь перечитывать и плакать, даже если
всё это выдумано, какая мне разница,
были кресты, не кресты, но я могу тебе,
если ты ходишь уже в такую
конспирологию, вообще иудейская традиция
и
бог Яхве, да, это вообще изначально
ханаанский бог пустыни. А до ханаанского
бога пустыни - это сын Эля, бога
шумерской цивилизации. То есть любая
религия, она перетекает изначально из из
традиций. И наша христианская культура,
она перемешана с нашим язычеством,
которое было до крещения Руси. То есть
это так или иначе переплетается. Ты
никогда не дойдёшь до истины.
>> А смотри быстро, кем бы хотел родиться в
следующей жизни? Ну как минимум уже там
болеруном уже не станешь. В
>> это я бы не хотел родиться. Всё-таки
>> не хотел уже. Круто.
>> А как популярность изменила твою жизнь?
Не боишься ли потерять её?
Кушать стрёмно бывает, когда смотрят,
сидишь и смотрят. Кушать стрёмно бывает.
И мне очень неловко, короче, когда меня
узнают, мне неловко и неловкость
чувствую. И
бояться потерять, да, боюсь, потому что
это мой хлеб, мои деньги, я боюсь её
потерять, потому что от этого зависит
благосостояние моей семьи.
>> А больше всего чего боишься?
>> Страшного суда.
>> М. А самое страшное там что?
>> Наверное, то, что злословил на
родителей. На вот такая вещь.
>> Ну, если осознал, вроде уже. И ладно.
>> Ну так я же не знаю, как может быть
заставит, скажет: "Иди ещё раз".
>> Блин, вот ты вот хочется ясности,
понимаешь? Вот поэтому люди и читают
святые писания, чтобы понять там что
там.
>> Ну для этого и нужны люди, которые это
проходят и рассказывают. Ребят, на папу.
Вот почему вот написано: "Почитай отца и
мать своего, чтобы дни твои были долгие
на". Блин, а вот если мы можем взять
одно, а другое не взять и типа ай хрен
знает, что написано. Готаю фигня, бля, я
всё читаю, но мне я вот это принимаю,
это про растовщичество мне неинтересно.
Типа, ну а как, на что опираться тогда?
>> Не, ну про растовщичество я нет, я
понимаю, почему это запрещено. Опять же
я понимаю, что любой вот эта вся тема -
это злая штука. Я понимаю 100%,
понимаешь, что я просто от этого
отказываюсь. Типа я и людям говорю: "Не
берите кредиты, нечем отдать". Если ты
хочешь в эту сделку залезть, то залезь
уже, если тебе есть чем отдавать. Вот и
всё.
>> И
про страхи.
Страх он как раз это и смерть самый
такой базовый страх, да? Страх смерти и
неясности, что там на самом деле не
смерти мы боимся.
>> Неясности.
>> То есть мы боимся вот как говорил
Пушкин: "Я умру, но не весь.
>> Умру я не весь".
>> То есть что-то останется, да? И что? И
как? Вот. И вот это незнание - это
такая, знаешь, это такая прикольная игра
создаётся. Кстати, ты не был на
холотропе, на каких-то таких вот
глубоких телесных практиках, может быть?
Нет.
>> У
>> прикольная история. А на может быть ээ
трансцендентной медитации випасаны не
дошёл ещё? Слушай, может это проведём
как-нибудь? Прикольная тема вообще.
>> Нет, да я, слушай, я я медитировал очень
долго в самом начале своего пути. Очень
и в трансцендентный, и с тела выходил.
То есть я уже эти все эти вещи, это как
будто другой уровень уже. Ну, типа, он
уже не нужен,
>> а мне уже этот мир абсолютно понятен.
>> Ну, я к тому, что вот халотроп мне, ну,
>> ну я знаю про это, про холотроп я
понимаю, ну, типа пере перерождение
такая история. То есть ты там
перепроживаешь тут смерть, возрождение,
и там очень, знаешь, такая интересная
штука. А страх блокирует нас к чему-то
новому. Ну, ты много мотивируешь людей,
говоришь, там вот туда-туда человеку там
машину хочу, машину боюсь угонят, боюсь
завидовать будут, боюсь то-то, то- то. И
я вот в своём клубе ска, ну, знаешь, я в
своём клубе встречаюсь с тем, что люди,
они даже не знают, что боятся, и боятся
назвать то, чего боятся. То есть они
даже вытащить из них это невозможно. То
есть и чтобы вытащить, мы погружаемся
вот на глубину,
>> в том числе практики, и это вылазит у
человека из подсознания через тело,
через его переживание. Вот можно
вытащить, что за страх дальше, работая с
этим. И как продюсер я, кстати, когда
работал, то есть у человека страх
проявиться, не страх проявиться, страх
осуждение. напишет коммент, потом меня
разоблачат, и кучу страхов. И
получается, я работаю со страхами, как
психолог, такой уже дипломированный, и
тем самым помогаю людям вылазить из
очень, ну, без большой жопы, грубо
говоря. То есть меня от этого прёт
просто невероятно. Прямо обожаю
консультации. Сейчас вот, знаешь, я
получаю сильно меньше денег, чем раньше
там под продюсирование всего этого, но
меня так просто прёт. Я обожаю просто
эту тему. Поэтому, друзья, все, кто
хочет, у кого есть проблемы, там,
страхи, депрессия, психосоматика, в
клуб. Ссылка в описании.
А, едем дальше. А что тебя в мире, в
себе и в людях раздражает?
>> Ничего.
>> В себе, в других и в мире. Ничего
>> уже. Ничего.
>> Я, [__] в своём познании настолько
преисполнился, что
>> То есть даже эзотерики уже не
раздражают, да?
>> Ну, так это же потому, что в себе не
принимал.
>> Всё, короче, ты вообще абсолютно всё
такое ровно, да,
почти просветлённый уже.
>> Да какой до просветления гора и
маленькая тележка. Просто раздражение -
это лишь то, что ты в себе не
принимаешь. Я в себе всё принимаю.
>> Ну, гнев там на на что-то вот что-то
злит, что-то вот бесит в себе.
>> Угу.
>> Ну, не знаю, там ленивый, там, не знаю,
ещё когда ты не понимаешь,
>> боюсь там чего-то там.
>> То есть ты вроде говорил, что в себе,
ну, как сказать,
>> ну, вот цели я не мог ставить недавно.
Злился на людей, которые не могут цели
ставить. Злился, вот понял, что я, когда
на кого-то злюсь, я просто что это во
мне есть? Унимаю, что любая злость коло.
То есть, допустим, даже сейчас человек
меня смотрит, что его злит, в нмме нужно
просто осознать, в чём проблема. То
есть, ну, на данный момент ничего не
злит. Я же не говорю, что я всё сейчас
завтра что-то появится, я что-то увижу и
опять же разозлюсь.
>> Но это значит, что я опять в себе что-то
буду искать.
>> Есть что-то, что ты не готов простить
>> для другого человека? Да, нет, конечно.
Вот как тебе Христос учит прощать.
>> Всё,
>> на данный момент не было таких ситуаций,
чтобы я кого-то не простил. Возможно,
что-то будет. Ну, типа, на данный момент
нет.
>> А, типа проверка, да. А и какой
сверхспособностью бы хотел обладать,
кроме платёжеспособности?
>> Блин, я бы хотел видеть свои грехи, как
они есть.
>> Ух ты. Во хорошо. Грех - это ведёт к
тему ответственности за поступки.
Смотри, как найти любовь вот в
круговороте вот этих сайтов знакомств, в
том числе твой сайт, да, я слышал, ты
делаешь сайт Близнецовое пламя,
>> и там как раз вот, чтобы люди
подобрались друг под друга вот
определённого уровня,
>> да, это не сайт, приложение. И в этом
приложении у нас в чём смысл? Там люди
регистрируются через ручную верификацию,
то есть там нельзя просто зайти левому
человеку, который там секс ищет или там
развести кого-то на деньги. То есть там
исключительно люди, которые увлекаются
духовностью, саморазвитием, эзотерикой,
психологией. И как мы это смотрим?
Человек перед тем, как зарегаться, он
записывает кружок верификационный, он
говорит: "Вот я такой-то, такой-то, я
настроен серьёзно, да, я увлекаюсь там.
То есть я не я хочу здесь реально найти
семью или друзей". У нас там и друзей
можно найти. И суть этого приложения в
том, что мы сделали вот для своих, для
тех, кто в теме. Потому что когда ты
ищешь отношения, очень часто бывает
такое, что ты находишь, а человек не в
теме. И там у нас, ему уже чуть-чуть
больше месяца. У нас уже люди нашли себе
отношения, уже люди счастливы, то, что
они замэтчились там друг к другу. Нашли
>> сколько людей уже,
>> блин, сейчас у нас из-за того, что это
узкая темка, у нас сейчас там людей, но
у нас мы как люди, которые ищут себе
отношения, они очень часто, неважно в
каком городе, там, в своём, не своём, но
у нас есть фильтр по городам,
естественно. И вот на данный момент
приложение месяц, там 1500 человек,
очень удобно. У нас система, у нас нет
свайпов, то есть у нас идёт по системе
рекомендаций, тебе каждый день
выбрасывают по 10 человек. А,
>> то есть ты вот вот этих 10 человек изучи
анкеты глубокие, то есть там что читает,
что смотрит, что делает. Человек
изучает, смотрит, знакомится. И вот
сейчас у нас идёт активное
привлечение людей за очень маленький
ценник. Потому что когда у нас будет,
ну, мы планируем 1.300 людей привлечь,
когда у нас даже первую тридцатку
перейдёт 30.000 человек, у нас будет
очень сильно поднята цена. То есть мы
прямо сделаем большой прайс. Сейчас мы
сейчас тестируем ещё, чтобы можно было
бесплатно попробовать, но эта функция
сейчас будет. Но сейчас у нас там 1.500
руб. стоит. Три. Ты платишь только, если
прошёл верификацию, и тебе открываются
эти люди. Классное приложение, с большой
любовью сделали. Вот, кстати, я и
говорил, что я IT-предприниматель, да,
это один из моих проектов. Да, крутое
приложение. Ссылку в описании. Вот
>> ко мне недавно две девушки пришли на
разборы. Там у одной прямо вижу, как
можно выстроить, что брак сохранить, то
есть он живой, а у другой уже
невозможно. И то есть вот в одном
случае, да, действительно, надо
развестись и сделать ответственность,
выбор, что надо развестись,
>> а в другом надо прямо изо всех сил идти
в сердце, в сердце, в сердце, в сердце
прямо. Вот, знаешь, когда очень мне
понравилась история вот с ней в том
числе в работе, она прямо всё вписала
сейчас в консультирование просто.
Никита, капец просто для меня
откровение, когда идёт что-то, что ну
разматываем, мы привыкли друг друга
обвинять, упрекать, что видим другое не
прав. Да мы же не видим зеркало, это всё
там. И я говорю: "А давай ты сейчас вот
заземлишься, немножко замедлишься и
прямо вот положа руку на сердце вот
отсюда задашь вопрос:
"Дорогой, мне сейчас вот на эти слова
плакать или в ответ тебя". атаковать.
>> Угу.
>> А он ещё Да, ты там свою психологию,
эзотерику мне сейчас опять плакать или
опять атаковать тебя.
>> Угу.
>> Хорошая техника, да? [зевает]
>> И человек просто в какой-то момент
подвисает такой: "Слушай", говорит, это
работает, это работает. То есть он
начинает слышать, они выходят на сердце,
слуша, а души начинают друг друга
слышать. То есть без вот этих, а кто-то
не прав, короче, очень крутая тема. Вот.
И так сказать, в клубе тоже подробно про
это рассказываю. А ты часто говоришь вот
про ответственность? Да, сейчас
постараемся прямо, ну, блин, тема,
конечно, глобальная это, блин, я не
знаю, на следующий опять эфир, Пётр,
>> просто про ответственность она
бомбическая. Тем более, ты же сказал,
боишься, получается,
последствий того, что ты делал в этой
жизни.
>> И вот как бы понять-то, где я выбирал,
где Бог за меня выбирал, где граница вот
между этим, что моя была ответственность
и не моя. У меня сейчас знаешь, какая
прикольная пришла идея.
>> [фыркает]
>> Сейчас смотри, сначала задам вопрос.
Блин, не забыть сейчас про индусов.
Короче, один очень крутой кейс. Вот
смотри, ты говоришь: "Я, ну, как бы
курсы, не курсы, да, вот есть некие
советы людям, да, ты говоришь, ну, вот,
например, про депрессию, да, ты говорил
там, ну, вот люди, делайте то-то, то
то-то, выйдите, да, и, например, есть
там отзывы у тебя, которые там говорят:
"Ну,
>> ну, про депрессию книга есть,
>> капец". Ну, книга, да. И есть отзывы,
которые капец, он говорит: "Там [__] ещё
хуже стала, вообще мрак". Короче, вот
потом я ушёл к врачу. Ну, есть там
отзывы, можем поставить
>> под книгой.
>> А они есть прямо вот отзывы. Отзывы
открываешь, там на зум есть отзывы, есть
отзывы.
>> Так, но я не видел.
>> Да. И есть комментарии некоторые, то
есть такие жёсткие достаточно. То есть
говорит человек
>> так у меня нет
>> игнорируй типа врачей. Типа вот это
>> я не говорил игнорируй врачей. У меня
книга начинается. Если выписали
таблетки, пейте. Что за глупости? Ну, то
есть пишут, что да, вот ты типа за
эзотерику, короче, ты врачей игноришь.
>> Не, у меня, во-первых, нету никакого
курса про депрессию. Его просто нет.
>> Ну ты же говорил, ты книгу делал, ты
начал несколько подкастов сделать.
>> У меня есть книга про депрессию, да. Я
хотел сделать сначала её как в
видеоформате, а потом убрал, решил книгу
написать. Я написал книгу, которая в
первой же голове говорится: "Если вам
выписали таблетки, пейте таблетки".
>> То есть ты как бы полностью, ну, на
врачей тоже полагаешься, но заодно и так
сказать дополнение. Да. Я говорю, что
если вы будете лечиться только
таблетками, не решая проблему, депрессия
не уйдёт. То есть, если такой отзыв
есть, то, во-первых, от какого курса,
если его не было? Во-вторых,
>> молоды. Следующий вопрос. Смотри, ты
даёшь людям советы в любом случае, то
есть в своих подкастах, в разборах,
>> в шорцах, то есть прямо такие чёткие,
безапелляционные, иногда прямо вот
только так, короче, всё, говоришь: "Вот
надо так делать". То есть люди тебя
воспринимают как коуча, как гуру и
следуют, соответственно. Вот смотри, а
ты, наверное, скажешь 50 на50
ответственность, да, когда кто говорит
совет и кто принимает совет, да? Ну
>> почему я так скажу?
>> Ну а как ты считаешь? Ну совет, который
я даю, я за него несу полную
ответственность.
>> Ну то есть то, что потом последствия
человека ты готов принять на себя.
>> Ну опять же, ну смотри, если человеку
сказал, например, я когда какой-то совет
даю, я ни в коем случае не буду давать
какой-то конкретный совет, который может
ему навредить. То есть, что, допустим,
там поди,
>> а, может быть, навредит, то есть, что
русскому хорошо, немцу смерть может
навредит? Я вам расскажу. Вот, например,
про ту же самую депрессию. Вся книга
основана на том, что должен в блокнот
писать позитив и выписывать негатив. То
есть я не говорю человеку там, не знаю,
э-э, что-то там пойти, не знаю, выпить
что-то, что-то съесть, что-то ещё. То
есть любые советы. Вот я прошёл и
говорю: "Ребята, если тебе плохо, пиши
позитив блокнот". То есть я каждый раз,
когда пишу какой-то, ну вот какую-то
методику, я всегда говорю о том, что сам
себе, что типа понимать, что люди будут
это слушать до конца. То есть бывает
вот, знаешь, вот когда у меня была
реальная ситуация, когда вот реально мой
совет навредил, вот я сейчас тебе
приведу пример, когда я женщине помогал,
и она в итоге говорит: "Я не могу
выполнить ваш совет". А я там говорил:
"Не нервничать" и тому подобное, потому
что у меня кредиты, долги. Я ей закрыл
кредиты, чтобы ей было легче. И она
из-за того, что у неё закончились
кредиты, ей не нужно было ходить на
работу, и она спилась. Вот это был
плохой совет, понимаешь? Вот это плохо.
>> Не был был вопрос как раз про ошибки.
>> Вот. Да. То есть, когда я за человека
решаю проблему, то есть я прихожу,
говорю: "Ну, я всегда стараюсь вот эту
ответственность держать, потому что это
очень, ну, я именно отчасти от этого и
перестал вообще курсы какие-то
продавать, потому что ты в курсе
человеку обещаешь, э, ну, я всегда
старался не обещать, ты как бы говоришь
ему, что будет какой-то результат. Я
решил, что я лучше буду писать книги и
записывать про себя подкасты. Если тебе
кайф, послушай, как я это прошёл. То
есть книга, допустим, про депрессию, она
про что? Как я прошёл? Послушай, сделай.
>> Ну это же ты прошёл. То есть у тебя
определённые конфигурации тела,
определённого типа питания. Конечно,
нет, не рекомендую. Я говорю: "Пйди
проверься на глисты, пойди проверь свой
ЖКТ, потому что у тебя, может быть, не
синтезируется серотонин в кишечнике,
потому что у тебя глисты тебе
разъедают". Плохой совет. Ну, типа я не
я не стараюсь советовать какие-то вещи,
типа
>> не, ну, например, блокнот. Что касается
блокнота, человек пишет блокнот,
>> а у него разматывает так его
подавленные, вытесненные чувство,
эмоций, что ему пиши, не пиши, хоть ты
100 блокнотов напиши. Угу. У меня
приходят такие люди просто, ну, в
коматозном состоянии. Ты хоть обпишись
там. Его надо просто принудительно
сначала через практики, через работу на
ресурс несколько сессий только на ресурс
работать, вообще его расшкварить
немножко.
>> Вот я вот, да,
>> потом может быть у него появится ресурс
на то, чтобы что-то писать и что-то
будет получаться потом. Но вначале он
никакой, и он ещё может писать ещё
неделю, две-три, пять вот эти вот
блокноты,
>> и у него ещё ухудшится всё. И вот из-за
твоего совета, например, и у него станет
ещё хуже.
>> Хорошо. Получается, мой совет был в том,
чтобы ты в блокнот выписал весь негатив,
правильно? Ну, типа этот совет, это и
этот сделал ему хуже.
>> Нет, я не то, чтобы против, я говорю,
ну, я вот как скептик такой, я понимаю,
что это вот приведу тебе пример, тоже
была у меня женщина одна на
консультации, она пришла, и она мне
после консультации, она, короче, она
жила с мужем, но при этом она изменяла
ему с двумя мужчинами. И когда я ей
сказал, что ты мужа своего не любишь,
да, и параллельно ещё она взяла ипотеку,
чтобы вдруг муж от неё уйдёт. Так, как
обычно женщина, которая изменяет, она
себе подстилает соломку, потому что мужа
подозревает в том, что сама уйдёт. И она
ей эта ипотека разматывала. И когда я ей
сказал, что ты сумасшедшая, ты, ну, ты,
ну, что ты делаешь? Она мне позвонила на
следующий день, сказала: "Я из-за тебя,
из-за нервного срыва, попала в больниц".
Вопрос: она попала из-за меня в больницу
или из-за того, что я ей просто ей
сказал? Ну, она же пришла ко мне, я ей
сказал: "Послушай, ты врёшь сама себе".
Вот, вот опять же, я несу за это
ответственность или нет?
>> Вот ты сказал, что боишься вот этой
самой ответственности в итоге. А,
смотри, от, давай дадим определение, что
такое ответственность. Вот я предлагаю
самое простое, мне оно очень нравится.
Оно, смотри, какое ответственность - это
готовность принять в скобочках без гнева
последствия своего выбора. Ключевое
своего.
>> Угу.
>> То есть без гнева. Ну, потому что когда
с гневом, это уже не ответственность.
Это, а, ты, понимаешь, да?
>> Ответственность. То есть всё, я сделал
выбор, я получил результат. Моё,
>> да? Но опять же, если я сейчас буду, а,
например, используя свою свой авторитет
перед людьми, давать какие-то советы,
которые изначально, например, мне
принесут выгоду, а человеку сделают
плохо, например, можно просить человека
взять кредит. Я, допустим, у меня есть
правила, если челове говорю: "Нельзя
брать кредит. Если ты хочешь там что-то
у меня купить, нельзя брать кредит, но я
могу сказать: "Возьми кредит". И будет
ответственность на мне всё равно, потому
что я сказал: "Иди возьми". И он меня
послушал. Поэтому, когда я что-то делаю,
я стараюсь не навредить. Понятное дело,
что человек, я, допустим, могу ему дать
совет, он в итоге что-то там напишет, и
он там, не знаю, голову себе расшибёт,
да? Или я ему скажу: "Помолись Богу, он
голову расшибёт". Ну вот понятное дело,
что здесь, ну, ну, какую ответственность
я даю? Но если я пришёл вот так вот и
сказал: "Садись, бейся головой, пол".
Вот это уже тогда ответственность
стопроцентная.
>> Ну, неправильно он тебя поймёт. Ээ,
>> ну я я
>> это уже не твоя считаешь ответсть. Ну,
то есть вот,
>> ну, нет, вот уже неправильное прямо
понимание. То есть я я пытаюсь настолько
как бы там есть моя ответственность, всё
равно я же это сказал. То есть я должен,
я 80 раз подумаю об этом, я 80 раз
подумаю, что сказать.
>> То есть ты осознаёшь свою власть над
людьми,
>> конечно, конечно. А как ты не будешь
осознавать? Это знаешь, как люди,
которые говорят: "Я там рекламирую
казино, я несу за них ответственность.
Извини, пожалуйста, несёшь". Для сатаны
важно получать определённые виды
энергии. Казино.
>> Если вы уже хотите моё отношение к к
Лудомании, ну, к лудочке, да, к этой, я
отношусь клу, ну, вот к таким
агрессивным видам развлечений, как к
времяпровождению. Мы, например, с женой
обожаем ходить в казино.
>> Ну нахер,
отец.
>> Ну ты видел? Видел.
>> Но я что пытаюсь говорить? Я вот я даже
когда вот книгу писал свою про
похудение, я говорил: "Ребята, смотрите,
я вам не говорю, что это надо есть, я
вам рассказываю, как я ел, да, там типа
вот такое такое-то я ел или там вот вот
так вот я выходил из депрессии".
>> Хорошо, давай сейчас попробуем отделить
мою ответственность от ответственности.
Бога. Ты много видео сделал про то, что
возьми ответственность свою жизнь. Всё
зависит от тебя, всёвсёвсё. А потом есть
много видео, где говоришь: "Ну, чуть ли
не на всё воле Бога". И ни один волос не
падает с головы человека без воли Бога.
>> Да, конечно.
>> Это как бы взаимоисключающее
утверждение.
>> Это взаимосоединяющееся соединение.
>> Давай соединим, давай поймём, где эта
граница проходит, как она проходит. Вот
я решу сейчас что-то делать
>> и дальше вот есть решаеь делать.
>> Допустим, какая-то высшая сила,
допустим, я мне нравится назвать высшая
сила. Сначала сначала Богу говоришь: "Я
сейчас доверяюсь твоей воле". И вот я
сейчас буду делать веди меня. Я буду
смотреть. Если у меня как бы я иду, иду,
иду, всё нормально, значит это твоя
воля. Если я сталкиваюсь там по этому
пути с болезнями, с агрессией, с
>> А может это сопротивление, которое надо
преодолеть?
>> Господь бьёт сильнее тех, [музыка]
в кого он верит.
>> Ну это нужно смотреть. Смотри,
сопротивление есть два вида. Есть
сопротивление, которое приятное
сопротивление. Знаеш, а
>> тут не факт.
>> Нет, нет. Смотри, когда ты что
>> Дорога в рай похожа на ад. Дорога в ад
похожа на рай. Естественно, смотри, я
говорю, допустим, штангу ты жмёшь в
зале, можно её приятно жать, когда тебе
показывана, можно наоборот.
>> Я же говорю, а можно неприятно жать,
понимаешь? Вот это два подхода. То есть,
допустим, когда я привожу себя пример,
когда я с женой ссорюсь, да, и,
например, можно что сделать? Всё послать
нахрен и тому подобное, а можно, зная,
что я это люблю, эти трудности
преодолеть. И тут я как раз-таки и
увижу, потому что в момент, когда я
вижу, что Бог мне помогает, во время вот
этих ссор, у меня в душе теплеет, я
чувствую, как мне благодать спускают. То
есть ты чувствуешь Бога, даже когда ты
идёшь по трудностям, он спустит тебе
благодать. Если ты идёшь по какой-то
дороге и там у тебя просто [__] и
ржавые коряги, ну вряд ли там бок,
понимаешь? И поэтому,
>> ну, то есть если жёстко ты тренируешь,
ты растёшь быстро, но больно.
>> Конечно. Подожди, нет, жёстко ты в каком
плане имеешь?
>> Ну, то есть, если ты поднимаешь, как
штангу, но тебе не очень кайфово, но уже
>> Нет, я я стараюсь поднимать штангу так,
чтобы мне было кайфово.
>> Ну, есть другая стратегия тренировок,
например. Она просто быстрее.
>> Она быстрее и она она не сложнее, она
более выматывающая. То есть, если ты
идёшь с Богом, эти трудности, они как бы
у тебя мм они как бы трудности, но они
тебя не убивают. Знаешь, есть такой зал,
после которого ты выходишь и хочется
спать, а есть зал, после которого ты
заряжен энергией. Вот такие же
трудности. Есть трудности, которые ты
преодолел, и ты завтра хочешь новую
такую трудность преодолеть. А есть
трудности, после которых не хочется
завтра на работу идти.
>> А смотри, ты говорил, верность, что одна
из составляющих, ну, верность одна из
составляющих богатство, да.
>> Да. Да, да.
Йхами как бы
>> её опровергает.
А, смотри, когда мы говорим там про
шейхов и тому подобное, во-первых, мы
вообще не знаем, что там у них
происходит. То есть
>> так они заказывают из корни, чтобы им
зубы, ну, зубы выбивал.
>> Ну, смотри, опять же, это вот это,
знаешь, вот как бы мы люди обычные там
пытаемся очернить людей, которые наверху
или, знаешь, там Эпштейна показывают
записи, там Трамп с кем-то, да, ещё. Для
меня не существует суждения о мире по
другим людям. Есть моя жизнь, моя
ответственность. В моей жизни я вижу,
что я верен жене, у меня всё хорошо.
>> Ну я вот продолжаю ту историю, вот
человек, который хочет понять, как вот
правильно жить, инопланетянин прилетел и
такой говорит: "Там, как сказать,
многожёнство, тут вот одножёнство, там
можно жену подкладывать и вроде никаких,
так сказать, грехов, а здесь можно в
племени, если родился, то у тебя жена
взяла, пришла, ушла, сексуальная связь
раз оборвалась к другому ушла". И это
такая живая система. Нагамак
привязалато, она уже твоя жена. Всё. И
получается, как понять-то? Вот.
>> Ну, потому что так просто инопланетянин
не прилетит и смотреть. Он, если
прилетит, он будет понимать, почему так
в мире устроено. Если он захочет познать
какой-то опыт, да, определённый, какую
он хочет эмоцию познать, он тогда
окажется в определённых обстоятельствах,
которые дадут ему познать этот опыт. То
есть в моём случае, опять же говорит:
"Ты видишь, ты пытаешься найти вовне, а
я ищу внутри". То есть я не я не смотрю,
кто что сделал. Я я вот вот есть
Евангелие, например, тебе там сказали:
"Люби родителей и быть верным. Я буду
проверять". То есть такое ощущение, как
будто мы на других примерах, на этих
шейках хотим узнать ответ. А я говорю:
"Я увере". Мы на Евангелии же пытаемся.
То есть мы, смотри, мы смотрим
Евангелие, говорим: "А вот это я
принимаю, а это нет. Это моя, ну, моё
решение". Я тоже такой смотрю вовне,
говорю: "Смотри, у шейха результат. Есть
многожнцы с результатом. У него реально
результаты, а есть одножонцы с херовым
результатом. И, кстати, сейчас следующий
вопрос.
>> Ты же не знаешь, что это зависит от
того, что он однос или многожнец?"
>> Вот смотри, дальше вопрос как раз в
интервью Анни Протасовой ты говорил:
"Успех мужчины всегда лепит жена".
Правильно,
>> лепит жена, конечно.
>> Значит, неуспех тоже лепит жена.
>> И неуспех тоже может лепить жена,
конечно.
>> Класс. То есть почему-то вот за это
женщины ответственности брать не хотят.
Говорит, то есть если мужик, получается,
обезденежил, это значит он [__] А если
он с баблом, то это я молодец.
>> Да, естественно. Это правда.
>> Клас. Удобно.
>> Женщина всегда права. Всегда.
Всегда.
>> Мне что-то подсказывает, что нас
наебали.
>> В интервью ты говорил, что гадание на
кофейной гуще Таро - это снятие себя
ответственности, превращение из творца в
биоробота. То есть ты как бы
складываешься ответственность, то есть
превращаешься в биоробот, то есть это ты
как бы поддерживаешь это утверждение,
>> что когда мы гадаем, что
>> Ну да, вот я типа хочу,
>> ну не в биоробота, мы не доверяем Богу.
То есть тебе ты как бы тебе дали
возможность сделать выбор, а ты говоришь
мне выбор сделать карта или гуща,
понимаешь? То есть
>> ну складываешь себя ответственность
тоже.
>> Ну вот это складывать ответственность,
конечно.
>> Хорошо. А вот смотри, тогда цифровизация
вот эта вот, знаешь, то, что сейчас
предлагают нам навязать социальный
рейтинг, как в Китае, всякие
принудительные меры,
>> опять злые дяди.
>> А, да, причём здесь злые дяди? Вот
смотри, это не то же самое,
>> что, пожалуйста, вводите, будет
безопасно. Каждый человек будет
отслеживать. Ну так это же так же твою
волю забирает.
>> Какую волю? У тебя воля. Свобода воли.
>> Если я свободен внутри,
>> ответственность твоя.
>> Я внутри свободен. Ты понимаешь? У тебя
ты меня не хочешь слышать, тебя это
злит. У тебя в каждой твоей жизненной
позиции есть какие-то люди, которые
пытаются твою волю. У тебя женщина хочет
волю забрать, правительство, элиты,
золотой миллиард, вот это всё. Я тебе об
этом говорю второй подкаст. Ты не хочешь
слышать меня интере.
>> Смотри, при этом ты также говоришь, что
ты боишься после смерти ответственности
за свой выбор. Я говорю: "Ну, я хочу
быть человеком. Я хочу отвечать за свой
выбор". То есть не надо за меня его
делать.
>> Вот сейчас на таксиста вызвал,
понимаешь? Таксист едет и едет рядом
такой яндекс-доставщик.
>> Вот я говорю: "Слушай, как здорово." А
он ошибся не туда свернул. То есть,
поэтому чуть позже приехал. И я говорю:
"Ты понимаешь, вот человек, вот он
ошибается, биоробот, он не ошибается.
Всё, он робот, то есть он не ошибается,
всё, человек ошибается. Поэтому я
говорю: "Я людей люблю", понимаешь? Мы
живые, мы имеем право ошибаться и
ответственность нашу вот где-то мы
ошиблись. Ну,
>> ну я хочу уметь ошибаться. Я не хочу
быть рошестоящая иерархия. Ты говоришь,
у меня нет авторитетов. Я в этом говорю
проблема. Я воспринимаю вот это всё эти
вот, как ты говоришь, там свободу воли
подобляет. Я это вижу как свою
безопасность. Они сделают эти вещи. Я же
ничего плохого не
>> Так это же не твоя уже воля. Не твоя
выбор.
>> Какая это? Что значит не моя воля? Не
мой выбор. Это вышестоящая иерархия. Это
власть.
>> Ну это твоя прямо
>> власть. Они, я им подчиняюсь. Это
власть, ты понимаешь.
>> Это их воли выбор. Ты просто
>> Ну так они власть, ты понимаешь, любая
власть от Бога. Они делают это не
потому, что хотят. Я какой-то там раб
системы и тому подобное. Я это
воспринимаю как заботу о себе. И вот это
разница между нами. Вы просто не хотите
рабами быть. Вот и всё. Это нормальное
человеческое желание.
>> Для меня камеры на улицах - это
безопасность. Вот этот фейс-контроль по
лицам - это безопасность. Если кто-то
кого-то сейчас украдёт, мы будем знать,
кто украдёт. Для меня, я сижу в
мессенджере, Макс, потому что я знаю,
что мне там не напишут, не обманут. Я
тебе серьёзно,
>> хорошо. Как обманывают. Очень хорошо.
>> Ну хорошо обманывают, но я знаю, что
будет меньше вероятность, что меня там
обманут.
>> Нихера подобно.
>> Но видишь, у тебя протест идёт. Я
говорю, это мышление у тебя ещё вот этот
сопротивление о системе. Я эту систему
принимаю. Я понимаю, что надо мной есть
власть. И опять же говорю, поэтому я и
когда даю денег туда, у меня энергообмен
с этими ребятами, я говорю: "Я даю ОФЗ,
я даю то и для меня нету, понимаеш?"
>> Хорошо, деньги у меня тоже есть, у меня
неплохие деньги.
>> У тебя свободы нет внутри, ты думаешь,
твоя завод?
>> Что значит свободы нет? Ну, то есть у
меня денег даже больше, чем у тебя. То
есть дело не в деньгах.
>> Свободы о том, что ты думаешь, что
кто-то что твоя жизнь зависит от
кого-то.
>> Сейчас про свободу, про ответственность,
про делегирование ответственности.
Сейчас я тебе прямо пример про индусов
хотел рассказать прикольный.
Мы с индусами, я сдал им дом, мы едем
куда-то, он садится за руль, знаешь, там
типа перекрещивается, типа вот как
христианское перекрестие такое.
>> Я понимаю, что ведёт машину отныне не он
вообще.
>> Почему?
>> Потому что он едет абсолютно просто вот
он смотрит хер знает даже куда. И вот
как будто его руками рулит не он. То
есть он чудом каким-то избегает три раза
аварии. Он просто у них же там,
понимаешь, как какая езда. Он ездит на
коршеринге, короче, [__] полная. И я
прямо понимаю, что вот в этот момент вот
он перекрестился, как бы, и он как будто
бы, знаешь, подключился к облачному
хранилищу включить найросеть, которая
мной сейчас управляет, и он с этого
момента не управляет. А я решил так,
знаешь, про уровень ответственности, как
я решил?
>> То есть, если ты творец, ты делаешь
выбор, ты несёшь за это ответственность.
Если ты хочешь на нишнем, ну, как бы на
нижнем уровне играться, ты выбираешь для
себя господина. Ты являешь просто тем,
кто выполняет то, что говорит тебе
господин.
>> А я говорю: "Я хочу быть творцом сам. Я
готов ошибаться, нести ответственность
за свои ошибки и познавать то, что я
творец. И я не хочу, чтобы надо мной
кто-то был,
>> кто мне говорит, что мне делать, потому
что это уже будет его ответственность, а
я хочу свою познать. Я хочу эту грань
реальности познать. Поэтому все мои
истории, Пётр, я хотел бы, чтобы вот из
этой точки ты видел. И, ну, зрители
также. Я как бы постепенно давайте уже,
да, заканчивать. Давай, если успеем, что
хочешь, чтобы с этого эфира люди унесли?
Главную какую-то мысль.
>> Главная мысль, что здесь нужно увидеть,
э, что мы с тобой говорим о вещах с
разных точек сознания, не выше или ниже,
а слева и справа. То есть, понимаешь,
вот тут главная мысль вообще всего
подкаста и того подкаста в том, что
вопрос самоопределения свободы внутри.
Вот знаешь, почему православных
некоторых обижают, что их называют
рабами Божьими?
Потому что у них забирают эту свободу
воли, которую даже они ещё и не обрели.
Сейчас я тебе ещё докидаю одну шикарную
вещь. Почему сейчас чипируют? Почему
сейчас оцифровывают? Почему биометрия? И
почему это неизбежно будет, это
произойдёт?
Люди не ценили эту свободу. Им, ну, если
взять религиозную концепцию, им дарована
свыше свобода воли, когда там вот это
плод познания. Нате вам, люди, вот
играйтесь, играйтесь. То есть, если
через альтернативную историю, то это как
бы был мир создан как матрица, то есть и
энтропия некая заложена как выбор
человека, да? То есть если был прошитый
мир такой, знаешь, как с биороботами, то
мы как бы уже и выбора бы не имели,
понимаешь? Прямо NPC, как игра, как GTA,
прошито всё. А нам дали выбор. Вот ты
теперь можешь осознаться как часть там
творца, как часть вот этого всего, и ты
>> понимаешь не ценишь это, ты это не
используешь. Ну мы у тебя это заберём.
Всё, чтобы ты понял, что она у тебя
была. И сейчас люди спохватываются,
такие: "О, у нас выбор заберут". Так он
у вас всегда был. Вы же не пользусь.
Нахер он вам нужен? Мы вас заберём. Всё.
Зачем он вам? Вы же не пользуетесь. Ты
сам сказал, да, что человек, который
обижает, что его зовут рабом, потому что
он по сути раб. Его это три.
>> Ну он и раб и есть. То есть он и не был
никогда.
>> Почему Почему тогда меня не обижают, что
ведут камеры и то, что меня в церкви
называют рабом божиим? Почему мне не
обидно?
>> Сейчас объясню. Объясню, почему тебя не
обижает.
>> Он в двух словах.
>> Я в в своём эфире, кстати, у меня есть
бесплатный канал. Там есть эфир про
чувство вины, про ответственность. там
более подробно. Я не знаю, мы не успели,
друзья. Ну что, ставьте лайки,
комментарии, так сказать, чтобы
посмотреть вторую, так сказать, точнее,
третью уже часть этого подкаста.
>> Сейчас постараюсь за одну минуту
объяснить. Пётр, как
>> нет ты можешь в двух словах объяснить,
почему я не обижаюсь на это. Почему
Почему меня не злит это всё? В три
слова.
>> В три слова. Почему тебя не злит? Ну,
это как в три слова. Не знаю, мне слово.
>> Я не раб, вот поэтому меня и не злит,
понимаешь? Сейчас объясню. Никита, ну
зачем я тебе себя
>> сейс объясню сложнее, что а ты делаешь
выбор и потом познаёшь чувство вины,
ошибку, не справился, не смог, и я
решение принял, и я не справился, не
смог, и я познал вот эту ошибку. И это
моё чувство вины сейчас.
>> Или ты пришёл к умному человеку,
спросил, что делать, сделал то, что он
тебе сказал, и всё, у тебя всё
получилось. И да, у тебя получилось, но
это не твоё решение и не твоя
ответственность, понимаешь?
ответственность его. Он тебе сказал, что
делать. Ты просто выполнил как
исполнитель. Но также уровни
ответственности разные. То есть ты
исполнитель или ты руководитель или ты
вообще лицо, принимающее решение или ты
учредитель.
Я вот на этих уровнях говорю, объясняю,
что ты на каком уровне хочешь быть. Ты
хочешь исполнять волю сверху или ты
хочешь быть сам автором и чтобы сверху у
тебя был Бог, например, или какая-то
твоя высшая сила. То есть я не хочу
никого сверху. У меня есть сверху мои,
ну, какие-то там родовые какие-то
истории.
>> Смотри, у меня есть мои высшие какие-то
хранители, какие-то родовые истории. У
меня есть точно какая-то сила, которая
меня ведёт.
>> И вот я хочу, чтобы эта сила меня вела
не какая-то другая.
>> Понимаеш, мне нравится она и мне
нравится и мне всё хорошо.
>> Ты говоришь: "Мне не хочется, чтобы
кто-то был сверху,
>> кто-то ещё вот помимо них я не хочу".
>> А мне хочется, чтобы кто-то меня был
сверху. Я хочу прийти в церковь и чтобы
священник был выше меня. Цитата
патриарха Кирилла. Непротивление злу
является пособничеством убийству. Как?
>> Ну, сказал и сказал. У меня просто у
меня есть в своей голове какой-то
внутренний компас, и меня я уже не
слушаю людей.
>> Ой, какая ж это всё [__] Какой смысл?
Тише, дядя Джонир, я больше не могу.
>> Я хочу, чтобы чиновник, который
управляет моим городом, был выше меня. Я
хочу, чтобы мой отец был выше меня и Бог
был выше меня. То есть я признаю
иерархические институты. Я вижу, что от
того, что я, допустим, не признаю
иерархический институт, ситуация не
поменяется. Я признаю его, и я начинаю
выходить на правильный энергообмен. Я
признаю власть над собой, потому что эта
власть объективна. Объективно есть
правительство, которое завтра решит,
будет так или не так. Вопрос в том,
когда я сопротивляюсь этому выбору, я
думаю, что они хотят меня что-то там
меня ограбить, лишить прав. Вопрос в
том, когда я соглашаюсь, я вижу, что
меня хотят обезопасить. Поэтому я
признаю авторитет и иерархию, и от этого
я чувствую себя свободным.
>> А я бы завершил тем, что я имею право
выбирать того, как кому сейчас я имею
право выбирать того, кому я хочу
подчиняться. Не
>> име подчиняться,
>> не имеешь. Ты ты должен подчиняться
отцу, потому что это такая иерархия. Ты
>> подожди, у меня есть мой отец,
>> да, и ты обязан есть. Его отец, его отец
это
>> и иерархия, и они выше. Ты это закон, ты
обязан подчиняться. Я очень хотел задать
этот вопрос Петру, но боялся, что он
уйдёт после него. Но он всё равно ушёл,
поэтому задам сейчас. Пётр, вот ты
говоришь иерархия. Это папа, президент и
церковь. Но что делать, например, тем, у
кого папа умер, сошёл с ума или вместо
папы был отчим? Или что делать жителям
Херсона, где президент и церковь
менялись несколько раз? И раз уж Петра
тут нет, то, дорогие подписчики,
напишите вы, что бы мог ответить Пётр на
это.
>> И ты обязан подчиняться, например, царю.
Вот так, что ты не хочешь.
>> Хорошо. Ну, царя у нас нет сейчас.
>> Есть.
>> Какой у нас царь?
>> Его зовут Владимир Владимирович Путин.
Это царь. Он просто называется
президент. И он имеет власть над тобой.
Ты переехал в другую страну и теперь
другое. Хорошо. У тебя другой
>> поменял религию, поменял царя.
>> У тебя будет другой царь. Потому что от
того, что ты не принимаешь эту волю, это
не значит, что она на тебя не детство. Я
против Путина не имею ничего. То есть я
готов вот это мне не нравится. Как вот
не знаю, есть пища для физического тела,
есть духовная пища. То есть я могу
выбрать это, это, это. Но я делаю выбор,
>> я принимаю так же, как ты говоришь, я
вот из этого взял, из этого меню и вот
это я не буду, а вот это я буду из
Евангелия, да. И я точно так же из
разных вот каких-то систем знаний, из
психологии, там, из телесной
психотерапии, то есть набрал. И вот это
у меня работает, это хорошо для меня,
это классно, и это я выбираю, и это моя
ответственность. Но когда я делегирую
свою ответственность на кого-то, и это
уже не я выбираю, вот я против этой
херни, как я не делегирую, я имею в
виду, что я со священником не буду
спорить о трактовке Евангелия. В это и
прикол. Вот если перед носит священник,
я ему скажу: "Ты прав, ты здесь сейчас
выше".
>> Так, а мне вообще не интересно спорить
со священниками. А зачем?
>> Нет, я просто говорю, что я в любой
иерархии признаю авторитет. Сейчас мне
кто-то скажет, как делать. А самому
подумать.
>> Это шизофрения.
>> Ну смотри, авторитет в чём?
>> Надо мной. Потому что пока над тобой нет
авторитета.
>> Хошо он религиозная организация. Он
создал когда-то там вот церковь свой
приход. Всё, он молодец. Мне туда зачем?
Зачем я должен его признавать как
иерарх? Потому что он всю жизнь посвятил
изучению Писания и точно знает.
>> Да, есть психолог, который всю жизнь
посвятил изучению по-другому.
>> И он лучше знает психологию, а он,
допустим, тебе подскажет лучше
что-нибудь поэто, допустим, очень часто
в церкви спрашиваю совету священника.
>> То есть, а, мне вот, как сказать,
гораздо ближе совет психолога и то, что
объясняет церковь через какие-то там
божественные истории, там Юнг, например,
объясняет через бессознательное
коллективное бессознательно, то есть мне
ближе. Это
>> понятно.
>> То есть то, что он выше в иерархии, это
совершенно не означает, что он умнее,
понимаешь? То есть есть очень тупые
иерархия общества коррелируется уровнем
интеллекта.
>> Оно, конечно, не уровнем интеллекта. Вот
в этой книжке вот там посмотришь, там
немножко такой, знаешь, эзотеричный
такой момент, где уровень сознания людей
определяет их
>> уровнем энергии,
>> а как раз таки уровень сознания
определяет их иерархию в обществе. А
сейчас в иерархии как бы самые
исполнительные, самые тупые, жадные,
жестокие братва из 90. Я считаю, что
там, в этой иерархии самые люди, самые
сильные, которые у нас боротва из
девяностых во власти, понимаешь, почему
я их должен сейчас как бы уважать. То
есть я подчиняться, да, но уважать я не
хочу преступников. Уважать я буду
уважать тех, кто выше, потому что они
уже выше.
>> Ну то есть преступники там.
>> Я не верю, что они преступники.
>> Ну то есть когда-то они всё это
пооджимали.
>> Когда были такие такие были условия в то
время может такие были условия.
>> Я подчиняюсь, но я ты но себя чувствуешь
несвободным.
>> Я у Как ты можешь себя чувствовать
свободным в тюрьме? А я себя чувствую
свободным, потому что не влияет это всё
на меня. Я признаю их власть, и от этого
я свободен.
>> И вот когда-то рабовладельцы поняли, что
лучший раб - это тот раб, который даже
не понимает, что он раб, а наслаждается
своими цепями.
>> Понимаешь меня это Ты меня столько
вопросов спрашиваешь, я тебе говорю:
"Ники, я свободен от этого. Ты говоришь,
золотой миллиард". Я говорю: "Я свободен
ты просто признал эту систему. То есть
ты просто стал частью эту сист она
существует объективно".
>> Так всё существует объективно. Смотри,
есть человечность, система объективно
существует. Есть люди, которые помогают,
спасают. Есть маньяки. То есть ты в
какой системе? То есть ты какой больше
поддерживаеш?
>> Маньки - это антисистема. Они выходят из
системы. Любой преступник совершает
против системы действия. Поэтому системе
>> я в я в системе, где я признаю папу, я
признаю главенство церкви и президента и
всей иерархии. И мне охуительно живётся,
поверь мне. Все, потому что тогда подо
мной может быть авторитет.
>> Хорошо, смотри, пришёл оккупант. Тут
сейчас
>> это не иерархия, Никит. Ну я ухожу
сейчас уже с подкаста. Причём я тебе
говорю, папа президент и церковь.
>> Есть такой психотип личности, которым
нужно, чтобы сказали, как делать.
[музыка]
Ты живёшь в мире, где вот ты живёшь в
колонии, и тебя хотят чипировать и от
тебя скрывают историю. Я живу в мире,
где я в свободе и в безопасности. Вот
разница. Понимаешь, в чём прикол? И
разница между нами в том, что у меня
нету те, кто надо мной стоит, потому что
я их признал. А мне хочется, чтобы
кто-то меня был сверху. Я хочу прийти в
церковь и чтобы священник был выше меня.
>> Да что ты, чёрт побери, такое несёшь?
>> Я тебе это пытаюсь достучаться. Как их
нет, если ты их признал?
>> Ну, потому что я признаю власть над
собой и поэтому у меня в подчинении
десятки людей, потому что я признаю
иерархию и я руководитель, и у меня
поэтому есть проекты.
>> Не, ну смотри, у меня есть руко, ну как
бы и я руководитель, и у меня люди в
подчинении. Смотри, дело в том, что
просто мы спорим с тобой, какая из
систем, какую я выбираю подчиняться.
>> Я тебе говорю о том, что ты себя
чувствуешь несвободным, а я не чувствую.
Я говорю: "Никита, на мою жизнь никто не
влияет", понимаешь? Говорю, я делаю вы
>> Подожди, ну как не влияет? То есть ты
только что сказал, что ты встроен в
систему, они делают выбор, ты его
принимаешь и делаешь так, как они
говорят.
>> Конечно, конечно. Вот и я себя чувствую
от этого свободным.
>> Ну и так просто легче жить. И ты
спросил, почему ты хочешь объяснить,
почему у меня Ну вот ответ просто так
легче. Просто когда ты сам автор,
сложнее.
>> Раз так вм смысле сложнее, не легче. Я
это себя не чувствую дискомфортно.
>> Ну когда ты за тебя делают выбор всегда
легче. Так за меня никто не делает
выбор. Я просто Ты только что же
утверждал.
>> А мне хочется, чтобы кто-то меня был
сверху. Я хочу прийти в церковь и чтобы
священник был выше меня.
>> Ты втираешь мне какую-то дичь.
>> Какой выбор? Но если эта власть она,
допустим, водит какие-то вещи, я
понимаю, что они выше, умнее и сильнее.
Я подчиняюсь тому, кто выше, у мне и
сильнее. Я не считаю. И поэтому
>> всё. Вот смотри, приходят с автоматами,
они сейчас выше, у меня и сильнее.
>> Нет, они не выше, сильнее у мне. Это это
военные действия. Они приходят на мою
роль. Потом они одевают рубашки. Бля, ну
ты хуйню несёшь.
>> Ну потому что, [__] я тебе говорю про
президента, про страну, про всё. Ты мне,
[__] про каких-то на Пётр, ну они же
когда-то так же с оружием.
>> Скотина тупая. Я тебя больше не знаю.